>
>>
>> I pledge allegiance answer
to the flag of the United
States of America and to the
republic for which it stands,
one nation, under God,
indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all.
>>
>> Tight tight
tight tight
>>
>> I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of
America and to the republic for
which it stands, one nation,
under God, indivisible with
liberty
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: ,.
>> KOBI GLICK: ,.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: , test,.
Play, Google Play console,
Google Play
Console.
Beta,
Play, what is
app, what is app, whas
WhatsApp, Omni drone tight tan
ight tan
Titan
Brawl, free
Free
Letics, deliver
deliveroo, app
App
Signing.
Spec space
SpaceApe, big fish
Big Fish
Games.  Sand box dome
ox dome Sandbox Dome
C ,.
applause
Plen.
(Applause).
).  Good afternoon, everyone,
thanks for joining us here in
the audience and on the Live
Stream.  My name is Sarah.  I
head up business development for
Indy cames on Google Play knee
Kobe, product manager for Google
Play.
>> Milenia, Engineering
Manager on Google Play.  We are
here to talk to you about some
cool tools we are launching in
Google Play developer console to
help you better release your
apps and games.  We want to make
sure you can launch with
confidence and better target
your apps and games to the right
devices in a way that makes
great experiences for all of
your users.  We will start with
a quick recap
of everything that changed in
this area in the past year
followed by big improvements we
have made to release management
flows in Google the Play in the
past year.  We will then go on
to announce new futures, changes
to App Signing, new device
catalog and device targeting
tools.  We have heard that some
of the areas are where you would
like to see feedback and
insight from Google the most so
we are excited to show you what
we built.
>> KOBI GLICK: Before we get
to knew features, let's start
with a recap of what happened in
this space in the last year.
Exactly a year ago at Google IO
we launched open beta.  A new
way to discover your a pps
running on Google Play and join
them.  Users can find your apps,
search them, join the beta
directly from the page and leave
you with private review which
you can see in the play console.
Open beta is a great way for
you to test your new updates
before you launch them live to
your users.
So this I'm beta allows you
to really scale beta programs on
Play and in the last year alone
we have seen more than 100
million beta testers on Google
Play.  There is another number
which we are really excited
about which is 4X growth in the
number of apps running a large
beta program
on Play.  We have great feedback
from developers like WhatsApp
telling us how open beta allows
them to get critical feedback
from millions of beta test ares.
It allows them to experiment
with new features and it's one
of the key ways they are able to
deliver such an awesome
messaging experience to so many
users globally.
And we get this
feedback from team Sem.  Smap
was one of the early adopt ors
of  beta testing on Google Play.
They use it for more than four
years.  Mr. Sen tells us how it
allows them to key to innovate
with new app
experiences.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Together
with those changes we have
launched a developer program
called early access.  Has anyone
given early access a try?
Couple of hands.  If you haven't
I highly recommend you check it
out.  This is a program that
will allow you to put your apps
or games in front of early
adopters while your game is
still
in development.  The audience
will early testers will be able
to provide you with valuable
feedback.  We grow a user base
of highly engaged users that are
more than willing to give you
the detailed grand you lar
feedback around how your game or
app is performing.
So currently, we have 25
million users and counting that
are actually leveraging that
early  early access program
since last year, 2016.  So one
great example here is Omnidrone.
This is developer of Titan
Brawl, and they are from Spain,
and they entered into early
access, and they saw more than
400,000 users enter into the
game.
They started by focusing on
engagement.  That was the first
thing they decided to iterate
on.  They then went on to
iterate on retention and finally
monetization.  So with early
access they were able to improve
their engagement rate by 50
50%.  I mean, that's a meaty
number and then later
monetization went up by 20%.
This is before they launched
publicly.
So we are really elated to be
able to see these Android only
tools and services move the
needle in a really meaningful
way towards the success other
games
launch.  Omnidrone has told us
that within early access they
were able to get enough traffic
into their game to really
analyze and improve their
retention as well as take on the
marketing assets and test that
in store experiments before
going live.  They also told us
that that private feedback was
invaluable.
One of the great features
about early access is that users
cannot rate your game or app at
that time.  So all of that
great feedback you are getting
from them does not actually
impact your store ratings.  It's
helped them to improve their
game experience based on that
user feedback, which is always a
really great practice to
follow.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: The
launch of early access is one of
the ways in which Android and
Play are evolving.  In order to
keep pace with this and give you
guys the tools to use the
functionality we build to its
full potential.  We have
overhauled the release
management section in the Google
Play console.  App releases
replace previous APK page and
introduce significant changes in
the way how you prepare your
next release and roll it out to
users.  Firstly, we introduce
the concept of a release and the
consistent terminology
throughout the flow including
things like rollout or artifact.
Is anyone in the audience
using multiAPK?  Quite  a few.
So concept release is especially
useful for you guys.  It gives
you a wholistic way to look at
all of the APK's that are active
at the time in a w holistic way
and see which one of them were
added now and which one were
carried over from previous
releases.  One more important
the ability to operate
preparation from the rollout.
You had to do this weird dance
with you upload new APKs, you
activate the old ones and you
public the whole lot at once.
Now you can create the dropped
release and save it in various
stages of completion.
You can then go for lunch
come back, make other  changes
in the console and roll it out
when you are really ready and
sure.  One of the primary  goals
of the new flow was to enable
you to release with confidence.
We got plenty of feedback from
developers like yourselves that
they are b eing scared to
publish because they are not
sure what are going to be
consequences to their existing
and new users.  We also got
feedback that some of our error
messages are not very clear.  So
these were critical as we were
designing new flows, we made
sure that everything is much
more explicit in the new flows.
We now provide confirmation
options at various points in the
flow, which reduces the risk of
accidentally doing a bad or
unintended push for your users.
For example, we now have a new
page which allows you to review
the release before you roll it
out.  This page will  highlight
and warn or block you depending
on the issue severity.  As part
of this process we changed some
of the previously strict rules
around how we decide to warn or
block you.  This especially
applies to things like upgrades
and targeting across the Android
device base.  At the same time,
we added new rules to give you
more visibility into various
other things that could go wrong
with your release.
For example, we now warn you
if you are introducing a new
permission which will reduce
your app's update rate, or when
you are excluding some devices
which you were previously
targeting.
>> KOBI GLICK: Another
change is making stage rollout
front and c enter.  We love
stage rollout.  It's a great way
for you to c onfidently release
updates to users.  You start
with a seed.  If it performs
correctly you update until you
hit 100%.  In the new flow we
made it front and center.  It's
easy to set stage rollout.  We
also show you how many devices
you will target with each
percent of the r ollout and one
feature we got some positive
developer feedback on is the new
ability to set custom
percentages like the 3% you see
right here.
Since launching the new flow,
we havestein  have seen a
number we are excited about.  We
have seen 50% increase in the
number of developers that are
using stage rollout.  We love
seeing this.  Staged rollout is
a recommended best practice and
many of our top developers use
it practically to release each
one of their app updates.  There
are other really cool features
we launched as part of the new
flow.  For example, you can see
a log of your release so when
you push to 5%, 10% or 100%, you
can see a history of all of
your historical releases, and
one feature we think is really
cool is your ability to download
historical APK's from the
console so if you are trying to
reduce a bug from a previous
release you go to the Play
console and download that APK.
Moving forward, we are
getting ready for the world
beyond the APK.  Starting today,
and you probably heard the
announcement earlier in the
developer keynote, we are
opening, publishing Android
instant apps from the Play
console using a similar flow to
the flow you are all familiar
with when updating regular
installed apps..  So it should
be easy for you guys to come to
the Play console and publish
Android instant apps starting
today.
If you want to hear more
about that, come to the session
intro to Android instant Intro
to Android Instant Apps,
tomorrow, 1:30 p.m. on stage 2.
Now, there are two features
coming soon and we think you
will be pretty excited about.
If you are using or publishing
APIs to programmatically push
your app updates, soon we will
Expose new end point for
releases allowing you to push
the change to the Play console,
but then go to the Play console
U I, look at the validation
pages that Milenia mentioned
before to understand the state
of your release and only then
make the publishing action from
the Play console.  And then also
with the best tradition of
Google, launching and iterating,
once we launch the new flow, we
heard your feedback loud and
clear, how we should further
improve the process around
release notes or as we call them
What's new.
>> We know today it's a bit
of a time sync for you guys,
therefore, I'm happy to let you
know that very soon like you see
here, we will offer you a new
format allowing you to edit all
of your release notes offline
and then with a single copy and
paste action move them to the
Play console with a single push
of a button.  We think it will
be a big time saver and a real
feature you would like.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: We have
had a few developers using the
flow and sharing experience, for
example, Free Letics here,
developer of health and fitness
apps tell us that the must
managed releases page gaves them
a greatly improved status
review of their releases.  And
deliveroo is pleased with the
ease of use and convenient
overview that they get with
stabled rollouts.  Now, they can
see exactly how many installs
that they are expected to get to
that staged rollout while
providing them with a whole news
and exciting level of Carol.
Now, -- Carol..  Now you guys
can role out your app in game
but you still want to understand
how your release is actually
performing.
Well, this why we are larking
another great feature here, the
release dashboard.  Here, you
will be able to track your
release health.  So, for
example, you can see what your
crash rate is doing, what's the
ratings changes look like?  Or
how is your uninstall rates
fluctuating?  This is based on
hourlily aggregated data, so it
gives you a powerful way to keep
track of your release as it's
getting adopted.  You can
compare the release performance
to a previous release which we
think you guys are going to
really love.  What do you think?
Does that sounds
cool?
(Applause).
So hopefully you know that if
you are running a staged
rollout you can halt it at any
time if you are detecting any
kind of issues.  So, for
instance, if you are noticing
your crash rate is going up or
there is a big spike in
uninstall rates you can react
quickly.  If you halt a staged
rollout and the users that
didn't get the update, they
won't get it, so rest assured.
Then you can focus on
investigating and fixing those
bugs before releasing the new
build.  So if you guys want a
deeper dive into that awesome
release dashboard I was
referencing along with some
other cool features that we are
launching to help you improve
your app health, go check out
making data on Play work for you
t omorrow, 1:30 p.m. over at
stage
1.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Let's
move on.  As Android developers,
your signing key insures
integrity of your app.  That
makes it very important.  Lost
or compromised keys are a very
serious issue.  I hope that this
didn't happen to any of you,
but in fact this is one of the
most commonly reported issues to
our operations team.  This is
why we are very excited to be
announcing another important
feature, Google Play App
Signing.  If you join this
program, you will let Google
Play manage your key and sign
your app before delivering it to
users.
For new apps, we can simply
generate a key for you.  For
existing apps, we provide you a
flow through which you can
securely hand over the keys to
us.  After that, you don't have
to worry about balancing
security and convenience of
access by, for example, storing
your key in a version control
system.  You can even delete it.
Apps uploaded to Play will
still be signed but with a
separate upload key which we use
as a secondary authentication.
This one can always be replaced
if
needed.  Is
>> SARAH THOMPSON: This guy
here is super excited about it.
I wanted to point that out.
Thanks for the thumbs up.  We
have had certain partners using
Google Play App Signing for a
while now and they love i t.
Here Robin hood speaks to the
layer of safety while at the
same time it's eliminated the
worry of having lost or stolen
keys.  How cool is this?  Pretty
cool!
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Now that
Google Play is signing your
app, you can probably guess what
comes next.  We can start
optimizing it on your behalf.
The first optimization that we
have started with a few partners
is resource stripping
optimizations.  If you opt into
this, you can give us the
universal or so-called APK
based on which we will automate
generic APKs for stripping
redundant resources for native
libraries and screen densities.
When delivering your app to a
phone we will make sure we strip
out is it the libraries.  Is
this way the APK is smaller
taking less bandwidth, less
space on their disk without
requiring you guys to use
multiAPK.  This way we are
seeing over 20% A PK site
savings with some of the
partners so make sure you opt in
and try  this out when it
becomes available.
We are very excited about
Google Play App Signing and all
of the app  optimizations we can
bring on top of it in the
future.  This frame is optional,
but we hope you decide to join.
To learn more about App
Signing with Google, its
security benefits and the size
gains you can get with the
various optimizations, please
come to the how to How to Secure
and optimize your Optimize Your
App Google Play App Google Play
App Signing tomorrow at 2:30 p.
m., stage 1.  Kg kg when
>> KOBI GLICK: When I joined
Google my friend who was an
Android developer asked for one
thing.  Can we do anything about
this page you see here.  You
are probably all familiar with
this page.  I asked him, why,
what's wrong with this page?  He
is like, well, there are t
housands of devices there.
There is very little info on
each device.  Many devices have
the same name again and again
and managing devices in general
is busy work.  N ow, the Android
ecosystem has grown so
significantly because it offers
different devices with different
capabilities at various price
points.  At the same time, it's
important that users don't get
an app or a game that their
device doesn't have the hardware
to  support.  You know what
happens.  The user gets annoyed
because the app doesn't work on
their device and you get annoyed
because the user leaves a one
store review blaming your app
for something that isn't your
fault.
It's important for us that
you are able to deliver great
experience to your users, and to
be able to do that, we need to
provide you visibility into the
device space.  It's especially
important for game developers
because we are aware that you
guys in many cases build your
games according to a reference
device spec.
Therefore, we are very
excited to announce that today
we are launching a new device
catalog in the Play console.
Woo hue!
(Applause).
catalog, you request  can see
the full hardware spec for
thousands of devices certified
by Google for the Google mobile
suite of apps.  You see here
what we call the card view, but
we also provide you with the
list view allowing you to run
all kinds of quick operations on
a set of devices.  Take a
moment to compare the old UI
versus the new UI.  Pretty
awesome, right?
So what do you get in this
new catalog?  First you get a
full device spec.  You can
information like Ra,  rf an,
system on chick I.GPU, CPU,
screen size and density and the
supported OS versions for each
one of the thousands of devices.
You can search devices by any
of these attributes, for
example, you can run the search
that you see right h ere, what
we call the filter.  You can
search for all devices, for
example, with Android SDK24 plus
and a specific GPU.  One of the
features I like best every time
you search for devices and we
show you one or many of devices
we also show your app
performance on those devices so
we show you how many installs,
how much revenue and what's the
average rating that those
devices contribute to your app.
This is super important when
you are making decisions like
prioritizing bug fixes, or
making device exclusion
decisions.  When we gave the new
catalog to Pixel bury studios,
one of our testing partners, we
helped them avoid making a big
mistake on day one.  They were
about to include a device but
with the new cat log they
suddenly found that it has
meaningful installs, 4.6 rating
and actually meaningful revenue
too.  So they avoided excluding
it and, therefore, avoided
making a major mistake.  Pixel
berry studios tells us this too
many will be a game changer for
the
studio.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Another
cool feature are device catalog
groups.  It is cool to have a
multiple devices with different
chip configurations.  We have
heard multiple times from
developers that it's hard to
figure out what's happening in
those cases and especially to
debug performance issues.  So in
our new catalog, we group all
of those devices for you while
allowing you to drill down and
see each individual device
separately.  If you want to
exclude a device, you can either
exclude a specific skew or the
entire set of devices for a
single group.
Now, one big addition we are
introducing our device exclusion
rules.  This is the ability to
exclude devices based on
performance indicators.  For
example, if you are developing a
ridge graphics game you may
struggle to get it to perform
well on devices with less than
a512 Meg or one GB of Ra.  In
which case you may want to
exclude the entire group of
devices with less Ram than that
or if you discover a bug you may
excludes  devices with a system
chip.  This enables you to stop
deployment, and deploy the fix
to the affected  users as soon
as it's ready.
When you create an exclusion
rule, similar to what Kobi was
saying, we show you which
devices you are about to
exclude, how much installs you
are making from the devices and
how much revenue you are making
which is pretty important
information where you are making
a decision like this.  To save
more time, we allow you to copy
a list of excluded devices from
another one of your apps to make
it
quicker.
>> KOBI GLICK: We heard from
a bunch of developers that they
love this feature.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Really?
Cool.  So we know you want to
exclude as few devices as
possible.  Android is great
because it
has a vast reach and because
users around the world are using
a great and diverse device set.
We do acknowledge that
sometimes you need to exclude
devices temporarily or
permanently and we want to make
sure you have the right feature
set allowing you to make such
important decisions, including
validations to make sure you
don't shoot yourself in the foot
by over excluding.  You can
see, for example, that EA are
using new tools to launch more
confidently and insure players
get better experiences across al
l of their supported devices.
Similarly, SpaceApe games
shared feedback with us where
they found a great way of inin
quoarp rating, device targeting
tools to reduce costs and
improve KPI.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: I would
like to build off of what
Milenia was speaking about.  So
big phish one of our testing
partners has been terrific in
sharing a ton of feedback and
insight into the tool.  We
collated their experience into a
case study we will share with
you today.  But first I wanted
to take a little bit of a step
back and let you know that we
had some reservations as a
platform as Google Play that we
were concerned that developers
might support less devices as a
result of this.
But big fish illustrates that
this is in fact going to
facilitate the opposite.  It's
going to allow you to support
more devices.  So as we went
down that rabbit hole with them
with their first days of i
nteracting with the catalog, two
recurring themes pops up,
precision and quality.  Let's
start with precision.  So big
fish's mantra is to publish
games to the widest audience
possible and using restrictions
as a last resort.  My favorite
quote is right here which is we
can now take a scalpel into the
operating room instead of a
hatch heet.
>> KOBI GLICK: It sounds
safer to me..
>> SARAH THOMPSON: What a
visual.  Developers have been
going to the far reaches of the
Internet scattered across to
leverage several third party
sources of information about
Android devices and their specs
for years.  The big fish team
really loves the console dated
Android device models and
grouping where they can also see
as Kobi was speaking about, the
install revenue and ratings
numbers for each device.  This
allows you to make more informed
decisions.
So one specific example that
they gave us was that in the
past they had this running list
of low end device exclusions,
probably sounds familiar, for a
particular business unit.  They
were forced to search and check
against this running list for
every new title.  And given that
big fish is an extremely
prolific game maker, this was a
huge pain in the butt.
So they can now set that one
time Ram based device exclusion
rule and import 245 that into
every new game they launch
moving forwards.  That means no
running internal  lists, no
manual labor.  So this newly
found precision is leading to
serious efficiencies for them.
And we are excited to provide
you with a lot of oil to grease
those wheels for your
team.
>> KOBI GLICK: We asked big
fish how they anticipated the
new catalog would help them to
include more devisions, so they
gave us a real example.  In one
very tricky device trick they
had to use the hatchet approach
that Sarah mentioned before and
exclude 12% of the devices in
that group.    With the new
catalog, they estimate they can
take down this 12% to 2% which
means including many more
devisions.
This is a huge win for both
developers and
users.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Let's
move onto quality now.  Since
quality is near and dear to our
hearts here at Google Play, we
knew that giving you guys a
significant and centralized
device catalog would surely lead
to improved quality.  In
particular, the catalog can
empower you, the developer, to
create a consistent and elevated
user experience for Google Play
users across a broad array of
devices.  The diversity of
Android devices enables your
games and apps to reach
audiences that no other gaming
platform can do.
We know that this also though
presents some unique challenges
related to that
diversity.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Big fish
said it best, we are able to be
more proactive in our device
support of new launches and more
quickly able to respond to real
world
problems.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: The big
fish cave me this pointed
feedback of how the device
catalog is enabling them to
react and solve device specific
issues in record time.  It's
given them more confidence in
their early game rollout process
knowing that they can iterate
quickly against device support
as well.  So, for example, they
have a game cooking craze that
is currently in open beta right
now..  They decided to launch it
with actually known performance
issues because they knew that
while it was out in the wild,
they could also look for
unforeseen issues.  With
launching earlier and that
review feedback not counting
towards their overall ratings I
spoke of earlier, they could
pluck out those iffy devices and
disable support for those
devices in the meantime.
That then allows them to
iterate regarding device support
more quickly.  Then they were
able to insulate their game from
negative reviews, and that
would in turn not affect the
discovery algorithms on Google
Play.  So, you know, this is a
really amazing way for them to
set themselves up for the best
possible global launch right out
of the gate.  And we understand
that you only get one chance at
launch.  While you guys are
increasingly focused on creating
gaming experience with lasting
power beyond, we understand that
that launch window is still
really crucial.  It's the
foundation that sets your game
up for success.
Since the early Saturdays of
the device cat -- days of the
device catalog we are excited to
hear of other ways this service
will positively impact your
apps and games.  As we roll out
more prodly, please share your
stories with us.  We would love
to understand how the device
catalog is contributing to the
success of your game and your
business
overall.
>> KOBI GLICK: It's great to
see how open beta where we open
the talked with connects to the
device catalog.  Today we have
seen, we have shown you a bunch
of new launches, new tools for
launching in the Play console.
And we also showed you how
developers use them to find
success on Google Play.  We
showed you the news release flow
giving you for confidence and
clarity as you make app updates.
We showed the validation step
which makes sure you avoid
making major mistakes before you
release app updates to users.
We showed you how we made staged
rollout front and center
allowing you to see the number
of targeted devices and set
custom percentages.
We showed you how you can
save your release as a draft and
come back later to launch when
ready.  We also showed you the
new release dashboard allowing
you to keep track of your
release performance in real time
making sure you react to issues
as they show up.  And then we
have also mentioned that
starting today, you can publish
your Android instant apps
directly from the play
console.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: We
continue by talking about a new
program where dwoog the play can
take the burden of signing your
app from you.  We talked about
the security benefits and size
gains you can get with app
optimizations.  Last but not
least, we talked about the new
device catalog.  We showed you
the device spec, how we group
devices how we can efficiently
search and filter the cat loge
and how you can see the data
about performance of your app on
a resulting set.  We also
talked about the new rules
allowing you to filter your app
on the store based on the
performance indicators.
Here are some helpful links
if you want to explore any of
the things we talked about in
more
detail.  We are sure you will
like the new f eatures and they
will help you release with more
confidence, better understand
the Android device base and
focus on doing what you guys do
best, build amazing apps and
games and deliver great
experiences to millions of
Android users all around the
world.  Thank you.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Thanks,
everybody.
(Applause).
>> KOBI GLICK: Does anybody
have questions.  We will take a
couple of questions.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: There are
microphones if anyone has a
question for
us.
>> KOBI GLICK: Great
question.  Not yet, but this
area which we call go to market
will be one of key areas that we
will work on in the next year
including stuff like rethinking
how we do geo targeting across
what we call different tracks,
so stay stay tuned.
Anymore questions, guys?
Oh, cool!
>> AUDIENCE: Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: That's a good
question.  We are making like,
we are thinking a lot about
narrowing down the device space
at different stages of the
rollout.  I would say for now we
don't have a concrete answer
here.  We can't commit that we
will build this support, but now
that we launched a new catalog,
we are looking forward to get
developer feedback on how you
guys use the catalog and how you
guys stack rank the most
painful areas now that you have
the data at your fingertips so
feel free to share this feedback
with us further.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: You mean the
permissions in the play console?
Okay.  Okay.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: For
permissions in particular we
made recent changes so I'm not
sure when you checked this out
the last.  We are also looking
into this area very closely, so
hopefully some of this will be
coming soon.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Right
here.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: Are you
staying here for the next talk?
I see some guys in the audience
I can connect you to.  Just
sitting like largely just behind
you, so I'm just hinting.  So I
will connect you with them.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Short
answer is, yes, we want
everything to be real time, and
I think now they will kill me
now that I said this, but they
are behind you so they can give
you a better
answer.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Over
here.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: This is a
good question, one thing we are
a bit concerned about at least
for now, you probably know
multiAPK and you know how
complex this multidimension
could get if you start charting
by screen density and ABI, et
cetera, you can end up with a
lot of APK's
so we are a bit concerned about
adding another dimension called
country on top of that, but at
the same time, we do a lot of
thinking in how we enable you to
provide different experiences
to different users in
different geos.  If you heard
the keynote this morning,
Android Go is a program that is
targeting the next billion
users, and Play will urn  unveil
a bunch of functionalities like
represent the way we recommend
you guys to think about the
problem space and how to build
different experiences for
different geographies.  So stay
tuned.  This will come in the
next few months.
Lrve.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Key will
be per app per developer,
correct.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone).
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC:
Currently it's a Play Console
feature.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: I don't think
we are currently allow
targeting by l ocal, so not that
I'm aware of.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Yes.
>> KOBI GLICK: This is
similar to what I said about
like countries, right.  The
multimulti-APK space is very
complex and adding another level
of complexity, we are a bit
concerned that we will kind of
make things too complex.  We are
working on a bunch of early
ideas in how we simplify this
area in general, and when those
ideas come to life, we could
probably introduce like another
level of targeting once we strip
the current complexity from the
system.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: This is
very interesting.  If you don't
mind s taying a little bit, I
would like to ask you about the
use case a little bit more to
make sure I understand.
>> KOBI GLICK: We will take
one last question because we are
running out of time.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone)
.
>> KOBI GLICK: When you say
all of this --
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
microphone).
>> KOBI GLICK: You mean the
devices information?  We don't
have an API yet.  We are
considering our options around
exporting this data, so we might
be able to export this data.
I'm not sure at least in the, in
the near future, I'm not sure
that we will expose an API for
managing those things from an
API, rather just dropping an
export of the device catalog to
you guys.  Cool.
>> MILENIA NIKOLIC: Thank
you very much.
>> SARAH THOMPSON: Thanks
for coming, enjoy the rest of I/
O.
(Concluded
at 4:43CT)
.
>
RAW FILE
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
4:00 PM CT
STAGE 2
NEW RELEASE & DEVICE
TARGETING TOOLS OR: HOW I
LEARNED TO STOP WORRYING & LOVE
ANDROID DIVERSITY!
>>
everyone!  Welcome to our talk
on the fact that no one likes
crashing or janky apps I'm
Lydia, a technical program
manager on Android.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI:
Engineering Manager on Google
Play.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Product
manager for an droi vitals.
Hands up who likes one star
ratings?  We have one person in
the wrong talk.  I'm sorry, but
the people who don't like one
star ratings are in the right
place.  So we are here to tell
you how you can Engineer your
app for high performance with
the new tools available on
Android and other than Google
Play.
We are going to start off
talking about why performance
matters in general and then we
will jump into the news
initiative we have around
Android vitals and how we have
simplified it for you to take
action easier by using concept
of bad behaviors.  Then we will
jump into how you can detect and
fix issues most effectively to
be able to have success.  Great.
So for the people who want to
avoid those one star ratings,
the number one way you can do
that is by focusing on stability
of your applications.  We put
Google's Machine Learning to
work to be able to figure out
what are people talking about in
one star ratings.  50% of one
star ratings are talking about
stability and bugs.
Then once you fix those
issues, how request  can you get
to a five star app.  If you
want to get to a five star app
focusing on design, usability
and speed because 60% of reviews
are talking about those topics.
Don't just take our word for
it, or more likely Google
Machine Learning's word for it,
you can take developer's words.
The Busuu team found that
focusing on performance and
making that a part of their
culture, they were able to
increase their star rating as a
result.  The Big Fish Games
team have even seen increases in
retention by focusing on
performance.  At Google and
specifically within Android, we
are obsessed with our
performance and device
performance.  We have been
obsessing over this for a number
of years now.
Back in 2012 we launched
project butter with jelly bean.
Since then, we have launched
the dose mode, project vocal can
and this year a bunch of new
tools in Android O and the
ability for you to get insights
with Android vitals.
So what is an void vitals?
You might have seen in in the
keynote earlier today.  This is
the new
new initiative for you to gain
new insights across Core
performance metrics.  The three
we are starting with are
stability, battery, and render
times.  You will see many more
come over the course of the next
few months and we will be able
to give you those insights on
Android and on the Play Console.
we are launching today.  First
one is stability.  So everyone
knows that you shouldn't have
your app crash.  People have
been focusing on this a number
of years
and crash has induced the
experience of crash free user.
Now you can see your crash free
user rate and your crash rate.
You can also see your ANR rate.
This is where your ANR is a
concept on Android which is an
application not responding.
That's when your app appears
frozen and does not respond for
five seconds.
this is where we want you to
avoid using people's devices and
consuming their battery
inefficiently.  This is where we
want to avoid using the radios,
or using the CPU when you
shouldn't be and you don't need
to.  The next area is
rendering.  So this is where we
want to be able to help you
understand how you can provide
silky smooth experience to your
users so they feel like your app
is smooth and fluid on their
device.  We swr two metrics we
will introduce you today to help
you deeply understand that
area.
So we are talking about three
major performance areas here.
And within each performance area
we are going to be introducing
two metrics.  It's a lot of data
to be able to understand and
consume.  So we have simplified
it to this concept of bad we
have yores.  We take your app,
study performance data and
figure out if you are in the
bottom 25% of apps   according
to that metric we flag it to you
and we say hey you need to
improve in this area.  Let's do
a show of hands.  Let's say 5%
of users are experiencing that
50% of their frames are taking
more than 16 frames, 16
milliseconds to render on the
screen.  Is that a problem?
Hands up if you think it's a
problem.
Okay.  Great.  So lots of
people agree that's a problem,
and lots of people don't agree
that that's a problem.  Well, we
will actually tell you in the
Console when you have reached
the boundary of when that's a
problem and you are in the
bottom 25%.  Right now that's at
about 2% of users experiencing
that rate will actually be
flagged and that is putting you
in the bottom 25% so we are
trying to simplify is for you so
you can be able to understand
where you are positioned
according to the benchmark.
So where do you see this
data?  You see the data in a new
top level navigation item in
the Console called aandroid
vitals.  It's live to all of you
and if you have an update you
will see the insights I will
tell you about and Ricardo will
tell you about now.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: So as
Fergus said we just launched a
new section called Android
vitals, and it is available to
all of you today and you can
check it out now.  What is it
does, it summarizes all of the
findings that we have about your
app performance across three
domains that fearing Gus
mentioned, stability, battery,
and rendering.  It works out of
the box without any integration
needed.  No SDKs to add, nothing
to add to your multi-APK size.
The data that you find there is
collected from millions of
users that have opted in to
share diagnostic information
with Google to help all of you
understand and improve quality
of apps.
Android vitals also
highlights whenever at any given
time there is a problem that
affects a significant fraction
of you're
users.  You can see the related
marks to indicate you should be
looking at rendering and fsh if
there is an issue there.  You
can use this as the first port
of call to understand your
performance.  We will spend time
to go into detail on stability,
battery and rendering.
Stability is about crashes and
ANR reports, applications not
responding.
Until today, the only way for
an ANR or a crash to surface in
the Play Console is was if your
users explicitly acknowledge a
dialogue an the phone for each
ANR crash to be reported.  And
this is obviously tedious and it
leads to a low volume of crash
and ANR reports.
The first thing we have done
is we have greatly reduced user
friction.  As I mentioned, the
data that you find there comes
from user that's have opted in
to share diagnostic information.
Opt in typically h appens only
one when I person activates a
new phone, and that is a very
low friction.
So this means that in the
Play Console, now you see over
100 fold coverage in the number
of reports with reports coming
from users running versions of
an destroyed as old as jelly
bean.  And this reaches 98% of
the devices that Play service is
installed.  Let's start with
the first domain, stability.
What are the bad behaviors we
want to flag out there?
Crashes, and application not
responding which is application
freezes.
For sure you never really
want any user of your app to
experience one of them, and so
we define these bad  behaviors
in terms of percentage of users
that are experiencing any of
them in any given day.  You may
be familiar with the equivalent
metric that other crash
reporting tools have introduces,
crash for users and so for the
next minutes I will focus on
ANR specifically.  What is ANR.
ANR means application not
responding and this happens when
your application freezes and
stops responding to user input.
This could be because you have
a deadlock in your code, because
you have a UI thread which is
low or you have background
receivers that do not complete
within a meaningful amount of
time.
ANRs are super disruptive of
the user experience and you
should aim to never have any of
them.  Because the application
is frozen during an ANR it means
you cannot typically use a
crash reporting SDK to collect
them.  On the other side, the
Android platform tracks all of
them automatically so they are
all available in the Play
Console without you having to do
anything at
all.  You just go to the Android
vital section and in is there
you will find a tab called ANR
rate.  There you can see how
many unique users experience an
application not responding when
the app was used on a given day
across sub versions, device.  If
the fraction is significant you
get a red highlight to draw
your attention to you can focus
on the most prominent issues and
dive into the d etails.  You
can click there.  Related ANR
section, and in there, you
arrive in the ANR in crisis
section of the Play Console.
Here in addition to reviewing
your overall crash rate and ANR
rate, you can dive into each
crash and ANR that has been
detected for your
application.  Android collects
ANRs and crashes almost
immediately as they occur.  So
here you find crashes and ANRs
that are typically a few minutes
old at most.  There are a bunch
of features.  We highlight when
a given ANR has been introduced
for the first time in your most
recent app version with those
little orange highlights.
You can track the quality of
your last release.  You also get
to see the number of unique
users that have been affected by
that particular ANR so you can
distinguish between high volume
issues affecting only a handful
of users versus ones that are
affecting a significant fraction
of your user base.  You can
dive into the details and
observe how the number of
reports and the numbers of
affected users trends over time,
and how it breaks down across
device versions, OS version, app
version..
And obviously you get the
full thread dump that captures
the application state at the
time the ANR occurred and for
crashes, obviously you get
similar functionality where you
get the rate that was observed
when the crash occurred.  So I
think this gives you information
visibility into what is
happening on your you'rer's
phone.  The next step is to try
to reproduce and debug them.
What I recommend is the new
Android studio 3.2.  It has
plenty of new profiling
capabilities.  The Android
profilers in
studio 3.2 present real time
data.  And I think this is a
great next step to debug your
ANRs because root causing them
often lies in not taking into
proper consideration CPU
intensive operation or blocking
operations like fetching data
from the network.
The CPU profiler, for
example, gives you real time CPU
usage for your app process on a
timeline.  You can dive through
instrumented meta traces and
understand which methods in your
UI threads are using up most of
the time and become blocking.
Similarly, the network profiler
displays net work activities on
a timeline showing that it was
sent, received and associated
latencies.
You can use this to
understand if a slow network
goal is making thread blocks for
a response or because of an ANR
this way.  And showed in the
keynote before, it's very easy
to jump into the code that is
responsible for the network
code.  If you want to learn more
about the profilers there is a
great talk norm morning in
amphitheater that I encourage
you to attend.
Now, we discussed how to
review how many ANRs you have,
how to debug them, but the thing
is how do you prevent them from
happening in the first place?
Textbook recommendation, do not
do blocking operations in the UI
thread and use, for example, a
sync task instead.  You can use
strict mode to catch accidental
disk or network access on the
application main thread as well
glvment another common case is
when you have a broadcast
receiver that receives and does
not finish processing within a
window of time offer your
broadcast receiver goes into
sync but you forget to finish on
the pending result you get
back.  Android 101, very simple
examples.  Most likely your code
is much more complicated than
this.  You may be using cues,
asynchronous separation,
libraries like RX Java.
The basics do not change.
The same recommendations apply.
Be mindful of which threads, on
which  threads the call back
for your asynchronous process
end up executing on, use
semantics in coding processes to
make sure that you don't end up
executing accidentally on UI
threads when you don't want, and
so on.
Finally, be mindful of
introducing deadlocks in your
app.  The traces that you are
collecting when the device is
connected to your PC when
debugging or by downloading the
tracing you can easily spot if
you have deadlocks by looking
when a given thread lick the UI
thread is locked waiting for
background one and vice versa.
So this is all I have to
cover about ANR.  The
fundamental question remains,
how much do they matter?  How
much should you care?  The
answer is you should really cash
a lot.  We look at apps that
have high and low crash rates in
place.  High crash rate, more
than 5% of users experiencing a
crash or an NRPD.  What we find
is that these apps have 30% more
uninstallation in the first day
than apps that have a low crash
rate, less than 1%.  The
message is simple, if user finds
your app and they experience a
crash, most likely they will
leave as soon as they find it.
I will now hand over to Lydia
for battery and rendering.
>> LYDIA FITZPATRICK: Thanks
Ricardo.  Android users care a
lot about battery life.  In fact
making it through the day
without needing to charge their
device is a top concern for
Android use  users.  One of the
number one ways we can conserve
power and battery power is by
putting the device into deep
sleep when it's idle.  This
means powering down the CPU,
radio and other component that's
would otherwise drain power.
However, you as application
developers can prevent the
device from going into a deep
sleep and  conserving power.
One of the ways you can do this
is through wake locks.  Wake
locks keep the device awake so
that it can perform an activity
on behalf of your application.
There is a couple of different
wake locks.  The first is a full
wake lock.  This keeps the
screen on and this is usually
used by a video app or a gaming
app.
Because the screen is on, the
user is going to be aware that
the wake lock is being held and
in full control of powering down
the app and saving their
battry.  There is another kind
of wake lock.  This is called a
partial wake lock.  Partial wake
lock doesn't keep the screen
on.  Because of this, the user
doesn't know that the wake lock
is being held and so if a wake
lock, a partial wake lock is
held for too long it can become
a silent and deadly killer of
battery power.  Because of this
we defined a bad behavior are
stuck partial wake lock.  We
defined a stuck partial wake
lock is one held over a an hour
by a significant percentage of
your users.
The Android vitals dashboard
will show you how you are using
and possibly abusing wake locks.
It will show you the
distribution of how how long
wake
locks are being held by each
version of your app.  In this
example, you can see the
majority of wake locks are being
held for a might be it or less
which is ideal from a power
saving perspective.  However,
there is a long tail of wake
lochs being held over an hour
which meet the definition of bad
behavior or stuck wake locks so
you can see we flagged this app
for the bad behavior in the
Android vitals dashboard.
In the Android vitals
dashboard, we will give you the
information you need to debug
your stuck wake lock.  Most
importantly the name of the wake
lock.  In order to prevent, to
protect user privacy, we will
only shows wake lock names if
it's been used across many
sessions.  This will prevent the
leaking of any personally
identifiable information.
Because of this, I encourage you
to use standard wake lock names
for each distinct wake lock in
your application in order for
them to be debuggable in case
they become stuck wake locks.
The reason that we are
highlighting stuck wake locks in
the vitals dashboard is because
of just how dangerous they are.
I mentioned in Android we care
a lot about conserving power.
So every day we collect reports
from internal Google users who
have experienced a bad battery
day.  A bad battery day is one
where your device, the battery
doesn't last as long as it
usually does or as long as you
expect it to.  They will send us
these reports.
We did analysis across a two
month period of all reports last
summer and we found that 30% of
these bad battery days were
caused by stuck wake locks.  I
think this highlights how
dangerous wake locks are.  They
cause real problems for real
users.  Because of this, I
encourage you to avoid using
wake locks
entirely.  Wake locks were
introduced in the early days of
the Android platform and since
then many of the use cases for
which you needed a wake lock you
no longer need a wake lock for.
For example, if you are doing
a long running download, you
can use the download manager
instead.  If you are
synchronizing data with an
external server, use the sync
adapter instead.  If you need to
run a background task, use the
JobDispatcher and if you are
holding a wake lock so you can
process an intent before the
device goes to sleep, use the
job intent services which is
being released in the support
lib B26 coming out later this
quarter.  Both JobDispatcher and
the job intent service are
compatible with the background
restrictions we are going to be
rolling out in O.  So it's a
win/win.  You get a background
restrictions compatible service,
and you don't get any stuck
wake l ocks.
So definitely check out job
intents services in support lib
B26.  If you are unable to use
any of these alternatives and
you need to use a wake lock in
your application, I will rehash
some of the fundamentals from
CS101 because they are so
dangerous, I will spend time
rehashing.  First, keep the
logic around your wake lock
extremely simple because any
errors in the logic could lead
to them getting stuck.  Second,
try to do as little as possible
while holding the wake lock so
it doesn't need to run for an
hour or more to do whatever
operation you are h olding it
for.  And finally, use defensive
air handling.  You can see in
this example here, if I hadn't
defended against my clean up
task throwing an exception, the
release method on my wake lock
would never have gotten called
and some poor user or perhaps
millions of users would end up
with dead phone batteries.
So if you follow all of my
advice and are able to not use
any wake l ocks in your
application, I still want you to
go check out the Android viet
will  vitals dashboard for stuck
wake locks because it's
possible services you depend on
are using wake locks under the
cover.
For example, the network
location provider wake lock in
this case that's used by
millions f L of apps to find a
user location.  If you are using
it too aggressively, it could
hold wake locks for an extended
period of time that become stuck
and you get flagged for that.
So in this case, you would fix
that stuck wake lock by
throttling back the number of
calls you make to the service.
So check out the tab even if you
are not using wake locks so you
can tune how you use the
services under the covers that
might be using wake locks.  The
second way you as an application
developer can prevent the phone
from going into deep sleep and
saving power for users it
through the use of wake ups.
Wake ups are alarms that you can
fire outside of the lifetime of
your application to wake the
device up to do some sort of
task  on bemax of your
application.
If you do this excessively,
the device won't be able to rest
and you will end up draining
power.  We have identified a bad
behavior of excessive wakeups.
We define if as percentage of
users impacted by wakeups that
occur more than ten times per
hour.  Just like wake locks, you
can get a full report on the
wake ups that you are using or
possibly abusing in the vitals
dashboard.  And just like wake
locks, you will see the
distribution of the number of
wakeups across sessions and you
will be able to see the names of
each wake up so you can debug
any frequent wake up issues and
just like wake locates will only
show the wake up name if it's
seen across a lot of sessions so
we don't leak any personal
identifying information.  So,
again, be sure to use a standard
name for all wake ups.
pattern of firing a wake up to
get the descries awake and
holding a wake lock to keep the
device awake to you can perform
some sort of task.  This is a
double whammy of possible bad
behavior because you might be
waking the device too frequently
and the wake lock might get
stuck.  Let's get rid of both.
A much better alternative is the
Firebase JobDispatcher.  The
Android platform itself does
have a job scheduler but I
encourage you to use the
Firebase JobDispatcher because
of its backward compatibility.
In the Firebase
JobDispatcher you can set up a
task to lune as a repeating
task.  I can run this every 30
minutes dialing back the
frequency you are running the
task is the first step to say
power so 30 minutes is better
than running it every five
minutes.  However, you can corn
strain the job to run only when
on a charger, this is ultimately
battery safer because it will
never ruin while usedders is on
battery.
Here at Google a lot of apps
employ this method.  Play store
will wait to auto update apps
until you are on a charger.  We
understand a user would rather
have a device that lasts through
the device than a latest update
of some apps so I encourage you
to use the same critical lens
when you are considering
scheduling jobs.  See if it can
wait until the device is on a
charger.
will talk about today is render
times.  Render times  measures
the amount of time a frame drawn
by your application takes to
get renlderred on the screen
hardware.  Render time directly
correlates with how users
perceive the performance of your
app.  Android devices render at
60 frames per second.  This is
based on the refresh rate that's
available in the screen
hardware i tself.
If you do the Math, 60 frames
per sect breaks down to having
to render a frame every 16
milliseconds.  As long as your
app is rendering every 16
milliseconds, users will feel
that your app is very smooth,
fluid and pleasant to browse.
If your frames take longer than
16 milliseconds, even just 17
milliseconds, it will get
dropped.  If you have a lot of
dropped frames, your application
will feel very stuttery, very
jarring to users so you want to
minimize the number of dropped
frames that your application
has.
row, and you get to the point
that it's been 700 milliseconds
before you draw the next frame
in your application, this is the
point at which users will think
your app is unresponsive and
they will begin to feel
frustrated by it.  You should
aim to have zero frames that
take 700 milliseconds or more to
render.
We have used both of these
thresholds to identify bad
behavior.  The first is slow
rendering.  We define this bad
behavior as the percentage of
users who experience more than
50% dropped frames.  The second
bad rendering behavior are
frozen frames.  We define this
as the percentage of users who
experience more than .1% of
their frames being
frozen.  The Android vitals
dashboard reports on both of
these  metrics and will flag you
if you are excessively slow in
rendering or too many frozen
frames.
Just like wake locks and
wakeups you can see the
distribution of r endering times
across
sessions and the dashboard will
also give you some other
statistics to help you
understand what might be causing
your rendering issues.  For
example, I can see a high
percentage of slow UI thread act
activity.  This indicates to
me that I'm probably trying to
do too much work on the UI
thread so I should move things
like disk I/O or network
activity to background thread.
These statistics though are
pretty high level and they will
just hint at the root cause of
your rendering issues.  To
really understand what is
causing the rendering issues you
will need to dive deeper.  You
can do this in three steps.  The
first step is to instrument
your app with the frame metrics
aggregator API.  This API is
built on the frame metrics API
released in an droi  Android
knew  newinget.  The 23R5EU78
mets tricks ago gator API
aggregates these statistics
across a series of activities
that you define and you define
the start and the end point of
that collection.  So you can
collect  statistics about how
long specific work flows in your
application take to render.
Once you have done this step,
step two is to  get the data
off the device and upload to the
Cloud off your servers where
you will then analyze it.  You
will analyze to find what flows
are rendering slowly for the
majority of your users.  From is
there you can move onto step 3
which is getting your device
out, walking through the flows,
all the meanwhile recording a
trace.  Once you have reproduced
that slow r endering behavior
or those frozen frames, you can
upload that trace into sis rase
T trace which will tell you
exactly what was going on in
your application when the slow
rendering occurred and not just
your application but what was
going on in the system as well
glvment from there you can
figure out what specific code
passes you need to optimize
rendering performance.  I have
just skimmed the surface of the
frame metrics ago gator API  as
well as sis trace.  Luckily you
have two more opportunities this
evening, Tim Murray, an expert
on Sys trace will give a talk on
how you can use it to debug
rendering issues.  Fipple as
hand lied over a  thousand Sys
traces and is an expert in the
field.
On Friday you can learn from
Chris and Chet about how you can
use it to understand your
application performance.  And
with that, I will give it back
to Fergus to close.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks so
much.  Thanks Lydia.  Great.  So
today we introduced three
performance areas.  We have many
other performance areas we will
be introducing over the course
of the next couple of months,
app start up time, memory and
network use.  For each one of
these performance areas we are
going to introduce bad behaviors
so ease easy to understand that
metric and how you are doing in
the  metric compared to other
apps.
A lot of the tools we talked
about especially on the Play
developer Console sides for the
Android vitals dashboard ago
gate over your whole APK.  If
you want to understand within
your APK specific performance
areas I would encourage you to
use the Firebase performance
more than forking tool.  It was
launched earlier today at the
developer keynote and able to
instrument app out of the box
comes network and start up time
but you will also be ail to use
counters to be able to track
whatever you would like to track
in your application.
There is a talk on this
that's going to happen tomorrow
and I would encourage you to
attend that to learn more about
how you can be able to use the
Firebase pore performance
monitoring  SDK in your
application to be able to
improve performance.
We covered why performance
matters, we  covered Android
vitals and the issues and
concepts around bad behaviors.
Again those bad behave yarrs are
high ANR rate, high crash rate,
excessive wakeups, stuck wake l
ocks, slow rendering and frozen
frames.  We introduced the
Android vitals dashboard in the
Play Console, we talked about
the Android 3.0 profilers, and
the Android APIs are available
for you.
So if you are not motivated
bay all of the things we talked
about around performance today I
encourage you to come to our
talk tomorrow where we can give
you a "Buzz" feed like talk on
why you should care more about
performance with the Play
Console tools we have available.
One of the things we will talk
about in this talk is the
rewards the play Store is going
to offer you for being able to
improve the performance of your
application.  We will get more
into the detail there's but we
will start using this
performance data in the p
romotability within the store.
Another reason I should care
about performance is we have 2
billion users on Android.  It's
a lot of users.  If you improve
the battery life of your device
and of the device itself by
improving the battery life of
your app, then the user device
will be able to last longer.
They will be able to make mor
emergency calls and you are
basically saving people's lives
by focusing on performance.
Maybe stretching a little there,
but hopefully you get it.
Thank you very much, everyone, I
appreciate you joining
today ... we will open it up for
Q and A.  There are mics at the
top of the rows and we will be
in the Sandbox just outside of
here afterward to answer
questions people have.
Yes, definitely there is no
API available now, the way to
access is through the Play
Console but over time there is
an API for that data and under
will be an API available for
this data as
well.  We can't make promises on
that right now.  We can just
talk about what we have today,
but we will be offeringna in the
next couple of months.
Yes.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: If you are
using some of the Firebased
tools and using the SDK, you
have to be careful how you
instrument it to make sure you
don't have performance
implications on the app.  The
data we are collecting is for
all users who have opted in and
it's on the platform level.  It
does not impact your application
itself.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
mic).
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Broken
down by APK version, broken down
by dwe vis and Android
ndroid
OS.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
mic)
.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: At the
moment we are starting with the
six bad behaviors.  The intent
is so to expand it on other
performance aspects so size and
device is wrub is that is
crucial for the user experience
of how users can use their
device effectively, not there
today, but we are definitely
expanding to have a lot more of
these topics about battery,
stability, rendering and size
and network over the rest of the
year.  So keep checking and it
will show up at one point.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Stay tuned
for the Android vitals
dashboard and we will be
putting notifications in the
Console to let you know when we
add more
metrics.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking off
mic))
>> FERGUS HURLEY: So on disk
storage, RAM usage, process
stats, we are looking into other
performance areas.  Yes, cool.
Next
question.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: I don't
quite get the question.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Are you
talking about taking the ANRs
from the Play Console and adding
annotations in the play console
so you can pull it into your
own tracking system?
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> FERGUS HURLEY: A few
things on that, as Ricardo
mentioned earlier we do flag
when it is a newly introduced
ANR in this specific app version
and we are working on more
tools around you being able to
manage the ANRs and crashes and
with your work flow better as
well.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: You are
already mute them out for the
ones you have fixed and then we
will automatically reopen in the
Play Console if they start
recurring on a new version.
What you want is basically an A
PI to do that on your own
premises which is not there yet
but we are definitely looking
into that.
>> AUDIENCE:
(Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> LYDIA FITZPATRICK: That
is a great question.  I think
one way to control for it would
be to do the sys trace and run
traces on lower end devices so
you can see what is going on on
the lower end devices.  That's
my first answer to it.  We do
have an expert from the Android
platform here.  We have Diane,
one of the  original authors of
Android.  Maybe you could come
up and we could chat more about
this with
Diane.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: We have
time for one more question.
There is a ton of you that have
questions to we will be outside
in the Android dome if you want.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: We
collect across all versions,
what I mentioned is we will
highlight the one that pertains
to the latest version because
normally that's the one that you
want to focus on, but you will
see reports across all versions
of your app that you have out
there.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: The ANR
and crashes section where you
can see the clusters covers back
as Ricardo mentioned earlier,
98% of Android versions.  The
ANR rate is based on ones where
newer versions, but you can
actually see that in the Android
vitals section which devices
and OSs are covered by that one
as well.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: At the
moment we surface ANR as long as
the user used the app in the
program at some point because
the intent again is to focus on
the user to experience the
program when using the app.  But
in the ANR section, in the
crash and ANR part you will see
background and foreground.
Lrve.
>> LYDIA FITZPATRICK: The
jobs intense service ask
backwards
compatible.  That's right.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Last
question.
>> AUDIENCE: (Speaking Off
Microphone).
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Yes.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Great
question, so definitely we are
working with the fabric team and
the Firebase team to have a
wholistic solution.  We don't
have anything to announce today
but we will be announcing what
is the wholistic solution over
the next couple of months.
Final question.
>> LYDIA FITZPATRICK: We are
out of time.  Why don't we take
your question down here.
>> RICCARDO GOUONI: Thank
you,  everybody.
(Applause).
(Concluded at 5:40CT)
>
>>
RAW FILE
GOOGLE I/O 2017
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 17, 2017
5:00 PM CT
STAGE 2
NO ONE LIKES CRASHING OR
JANKY APPS? ENGINEER FOR HIGH
PERFORMANCE WITH TOOLS FROM
ANDROID & PLAY
TA3BEC
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
Www.captionfirst.com
* * *
This text is being provided
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the
proceedings.
* * *
>>
>> Steve Steve, Russ Russ,
Christ Christ,
foib,
fish,
irebase,.
Christ
sta,
Krista,.
>> RUSS KETCHUM: Hi,
everyone, I'm Russ Ketchum I'm a
group product manager aand I
leave mobile app Analytics.  I
can hardly believe it's already
been a year since we stove on a
stage not too far from here and
interest Tuesdayed Firebase
Google's integrated app
developer platform.  With it we
launched Firebase Analytics our
first apps first Analytics
platform we built from the
ground up to be completely free
and completely unlimited.  Since
last year, Analytics remains a
key investment area not just for
Firebase but for Google as a
whole.  And at Google we take a
unified approach to our
measurement solutions and so to
under score that for all of our
users, we wanted to formally
introduce you all to our new
name, and that's Google
Analytics for Firebase.
So Google the Analytics is
the most used digital Analytics
solution in the world.  And we
think with our new name we will
make it clear to all of our
customers, Web, app, and
otherwise that we are building
towards a unified solution.  And
now while our name is it
changing our commitment to app
developers and app Analytics
remains unchanged.  And we fully
appreciate that the challenges
that the developer community
faces, they are daunting.  And
there are many ways are very
unique.  Let's take a look at
some of them.
So building a successful app
and with it a successful
business is really hard.
Finding a way to make that
process repeatable is even
harder.  It's really, really
hard, but as Google, we believe
that good data is often the key
to unlocking that type of
success.  But for developers,
you also know that even having
access to good quality data is
in itself really hard.  So the
amount of time that people spend
on mobile  devices, I don't
need to tell you this, is
staggering and of the time spent
on mobile over 85% is spent
engaging with apps and that u
sage in turn throws off just a
ton of data.
And very few tools are
available to actually help
developers capture that,
particularly tools that are
within reach of developing b
usinesses.  But in you could
assume for a -- if you could
assume for a second that you had
a tool that would help you
collect that data, you then have
to be able to find trends that
are responsible for your
successes and failtz yours.
Even if you are able to spot
those trends not not good enough
to have simple understanding in
a vacuum.  You need to use the
data in the  places you care
about and take action and drive
your business forward.  These
are the type of challenges we
are building Google Analytics
for Firebase to help you solve.
So today we are going to talk
about Google Analytics for
Firebase from three slightly
different angles.  First, I'm
going to step us through what we
see as the core of our
Analytics offering, then I will
have Steve join us and he will
talk about exciting enhancements
we are  introducing today to
our reporting capabilities and
then finally Krista will come up
and talk growth strategies and
how you can use cross network
attribute solutions to drive
your business forward.  So
turning to our core, when we
approached Google Analytics for
Firebase, we built a solution to
be completely free and
unlimited even for the largest
of apps.  Now you have the
opportunity to understand all
data without compromise.
This includes all of your raw
event data, all accessible and
all for free.  But what's more
though is Analytics works simply
by adding Firebase to your app.
Analytics is just set up
automatically, and right out of
the box, you get access to the
most important signals and you
have all of that information
summarized for you at your
fingertips.  So let's take a
look at that..
So this is our app dashboard.
It provides summaries of all
of your key data points and then
has drill ins for deeper
analysis throughout the product.
I will step through and zoom
in on some of the cards quickly.
The first at the top is
helping you understand key
engagement metrics.  This is the
active user's card.  It has
daily, weekly, monthly active
users like all of our line
plots.  It has comparison to the
previous period and it quickly
summarizes user engagement.
Then when you look at a
different definition of user
engagement, you are able to see
how much time your customers are
spending actually engaged with
your app.  And ideally, that
engagement is turning into
revenue.  And so here on the
average revenue card we are
summarizing average revenue
peruser, also per paid user,
again, broken out by the same
daily, weekly, monthly
summaries.  For many apps that
monetize effectively they are
using in app purchases, in app
purchase is an event that's able
to be captured automatically
both on iOS and Android.  And
the I/O P summary summarizes top
transactions and as a drill in
link for detailed reporting.
So drive successful
businesses, particularly those
built around IAP.  User
acquisition strategy is key.
That's where cross network
attribution comes in and you are
able to use the cross network
attribution summary to
understand the best term forming
channels and how the channels
are turning into lifetime value
with a deep link to the full
report.
What's the point of acquiring
users if you can't keep them?
That's what you are seeing here
in the cohort summary.  Krista
will come up and talk about
techniques more in a few
minutes.
Switching gears a little and
moving down the dashboard, all
find device and app info.  Here
you are looking at the app
versions card.  This is the
device's card and it summarizes
the model of the device along
with OS information.  And then
this last set of cards gives you
more insight into use users.
Here we are looking at location
information and then by
sprinkling in Google proprietary
data you are seeing age and
gender information and then
lastly interest category
information so all great data
quickly summarized for users.
It's great that all of this
works out of the box and is
automatic, but you are not
limited to the automatic events.
We built Google Analytics for
Firebase to be highly extensible
so you can track up to 500
distinct events each with 25
different parameters and log the
events on a complete unlimited
basis.
If you don't know what to
track, we go so far as to
suggest different types of
events to you based on the
different types of apps that you
might have.  It's a great way
to jump start your
implementation, but it also
helps you understand even more
deeply around these behavior you
because many events feature
first class reporting.  It's
great to have it all brought
together and summarized, all of
your data, but what's the point
of  having it in a silo.  You
need to have it available to you
in all of the places you care
about.  So Google Analytics for
Firebase is, of course, at home
in the Firebase Console.  This
is where many of you know and
expect it to live.
It is lz available in the
Google Analytics UI.  So this
way all of the users across your
organization can have access to
the same Analytics capabilities
in whatever product they are
most familiar with.  But that's
not all.  Your Analytics data is
also available for you in Cloud
messaging both to understand
what's happening and to use for
targeting.  The same is true for
remote config.  Your Analytics
data works with crash reporting
to help you understand
engagement patterns that might
be leading to crashes and can be
used natively with Cloud
functions.  Cross network
attribution in Analytics works
in a complimentary way with
dynamic links, and for
Enterprise customers, Analytics
works across the Google
Analytics 360  360 suite.
One of the ways that it works
with the 360 suite is through
Google tag manager.  Tag manager
lets you remotely configure the
event measurement from your app
from a Web UI.  You can modify
events you are already tracking.
You can have one event fire in
response to another event and
send event data to other
destinations not just at Google
but with our tag template
partners including tune and many
others.
And then simply by linking
Firebase to AdWords your
Analytics data is available to
use for conversion tracking and
actually used as a signal to
drive all of your app related
campaigns.  And so while this
equips you with the start of the
right data in many of the
places where you need it, like I
said, it's really just the
start of the right data.  So
with that, I'm going to invite
Steve up on stage and he is
going to showcase our latest
announcements related to
reporting.  Steve?
(Applause).
>> STEVE GANEM: Thank you.
Thanks, Russ.  Good afternoon,
Google I/O, my name is Steve
Ganem and I'm a product manager
on Analytics.  Before coming to
Google I spent 20 years
developing video games and I
launched about 30 titles in that
time frame.  Let me tell you
there is nothing more exciting
than launching a game.  Now, you
work on this thing for months
or perhaps years to get it ready
and it starts to come together
and become fun and then you
finally get to the point where
you are ready to put it out in
front of real users and press
and get the feedback you have
been looking for.  And I know a
lot of you can relate with
launching your own products.
Last year right here at
Google I/O we launched Firebase
I got that same thrill, that
same buzz.  And since then I
have had the opportunity to
speak with many of you at events
like this on social media, good
old stack overflow, and
sometimes directly over email
and I have gotten a chance to
help some of you understand your
reports, but also to get your
feedback on what's working well
in the product and what we can
do to improve it for you.
If I could categorize your
feedback, it would generally
fall in these two themes.  First
would be that you really want
deeper reporting, and you want
real time features.  And I'm
excited to tell you that we have
some pretty huge improvements
in both of these areas that I
will tell you about today.
First, what do I mean by deeper
reporting?  I mean that type of
reporting that better, helps you
better understand how users are
behaving and performing in your
apps and also the type of
reporting that helps you
understand how ruer app business
is p erforming.
Sometimes this is a matter of
Google connecting dots for you
by a ugmenting data with other
data that Google has and
sometimes it's justs a matter of
surfacing data you are already
collecting in more insightful
ways.  One feature that's the
perfect plend and showcase for
both of these things is our
brand new integration with
AdMob.  You may have heard the
keynote preceding this but this
integration allows data to flow
between two platforms and goes a
long way to enable deeper
reporting for the 1.000000 apps
using AdMob today.  Showing an
ad in your app isn't as simple
as a binary decision anymore.
There is lots of decisions to
make.  There is a decision of
what primary network to use,
what immediate yated networks to
use, what formats, refresh
rates how to render native ads
and if you are using rewarded
ads, how much reward to give to
users.
Beyond that, showing an ad in
your app isn't something you do
in a vacuum.  This is a
sacrifice of the real estate of
your app, and you need to make
sure that as you are earning
revenue you are not sacrificing
the user experience or else you
might win the revenue battle and
lose the overall user
engagement and retention war.
You need to pick the right
winning strategy for your app.
Analytics can help you measure
that winning strategy, Burt
first you need to get your AdMob
data into Analytics.  That's
exactly what we have done for
you with this integration.  It's
entirely automatic just by
dropping in the supported
versions of our SDKs in your
app, we will automatically bring
AdMob impressions and clicks
into AdMob not just, or, iemgz,
into Analytics.  Not just for
AdMob but networks you mediate
through AdMob as well.  And
because we have the great
integration with AdMob we can
factor it into cease business
performance indicators like
average revenue peruser.  So now
you have an overall revenue
metric that take into account
both purchase revenue and ads
revenue.
You can go deeper with this.
In addition to showing you
these metrics, you can break it
down in a number of ways.  We
let you break them down by ad
unit, ad format, ad source and
also by screen because we nose
where these ads are being shown
in your app, we can help you
understand which screens are
performing better in terms of
your ad
revenue.  Because all of is this
is 457ing at the event level
you can apply audience filters
and property filters to
understand how ad performance
differs among different segments
of your user base.  That's
important when trying to build a
winning strategy for your app
for advertising because then you
can AB test and understand how
different strategies actually
perform.  We have given some of
you early access and some of the
feedback has been incredibly
encouraging.  President of B
works games had this to say.  He
said this integration has
completely changed the way we
think about game design and
montization.  And we hope it can
do the same for you as well.
Help you fundamentally think
about what your ad strategy
should be since now you can
measure it and understand not
just the impact on revenue, but
also on user engagement and
retention.
So needless to say we are
excited to get this in your
hands.  If you are interested in
trying this out, it's available
today.  Just check out our help
center article for more
information.  And you can check
out the reports as well in our
demo project for Firebase which
is available on the Firebase
Console through the link explore
demo p roject, and you can see
this reporting in action for a
real app.  We also have a
session entirely dedicated to
this on Friday that you
definitely should check out.
It's called AdMob and Firebase,
better together.
Continuing with the theme of
deeper reporting, I want to
touch on something that you have
been really focus about since
launch of last year.  It
resolves around event
parameters.  Events are the data
points of Analytics.  You log
events to tell us what's
happening in your app, what
actions users are taking and you
associate parameters with them
to contextualize those events so
it's not just that a purchase
occurred but you can tell us
what product was purchased.  As
Russ mentioned our API is
extensible and you can log
custom events that correspond to
specific features you have in
your app and attach parameters
to those as well, although you
can use those events and
parameters, those custom events
and parameters in audience
definitions, reporting around
the values of those parameters
has historically been related
only to those suggested events
that we pre corroborate for
different business verse calls
that Russ showed you.
You have been vocal about the
need to see reporting on
parameter values in Analytics so
today I'm excited to tell you
we made that available to you.
We are launching parameter
reporting in Analytics.  So
tablas R.
(Applause).
And this is available now,
you don't need a new SDK for it.
If you go to your event detail
report in Analytics, you will
see the prompt to add event
parameters you want to see
reporting on.  You can register
up to 50 event parameters.  Tip
dli you will send us either a
number or text parameter.  Here
is what you will get out of
that.
When you send us a number, we
will produce a sum met Atlantic
and average metric.  There is
different use cases for both of
those.  So would you pass, in
this case, I'm showing a screen
where for a product purchase I
want to show some metric of the
product value.  I have a high
level view of how much money I'm
making through these purchases
compared to the last period.
It's simple and easy to
understand but it doesn't have
to be revenue related.  You can
do this to track any high level
key performance indicators in
your app.  In you have a music
streaming app you want to
measure the total amount of time
users are spending listening to
music or watching video or if
you have a travel app and you
want to see how far your users
are traveling, you can measure
that as well.
And we compare it against the
previous period so you can
filter this as well and see how
it differs among the different
segments of your user base.
Additionally we also supply you
with an average metric.
Pictures here is an event for my
game called level end where I
log the total score.  Looking at
the average here plotted
against the previous period I
can see what the average scores
are for users who are playing my
game.
And I find the average one to
be actually especially
insightful.  We will have to see
what you come up with.  Some
common thing you can use this
for, useful questions you can
answer are things like on
average how many friends does a
user have when they make the
first post to my social network?
On average how much time does
a user spend in Ms. App before
they make the first purchase?
How far are users traveling in
their morning jog?  And now it's
a singe to  cinch to get
answers in AdMob by registering
parameters.  You are passing us
text parameters.  Here is an
example from my app.  It's a
skateboarding game and users are
u nlocking various achievements
and now I can get a breakdown
of the most popular achievements
that they are unlocking and
graph them against each other to
see what the popularity and
distributions are like.
You can use in this in your
app to see what is the most
popular content or search terms
and also on what screens are
certain actions taking place.
And, again, as I mentioned with
all Analytics reports, you can
then filter these reports by
your audience segments and user
properties to see how behavior
is different among the different
segments of the user base
because it will be and the
better you understand that the
more tailored you can make your
app experience and your app
updates so serve your audience.
I'm personally very excited
about this one.  It's something
I wanted in my own apps and so
I'm sorry anxious to put it in
your hands so you can give it a
shot too.  This is available
today.  You don't need a new SDK
for it.  You may have noticed I
mentioned screens a couple of
times both in the context of the
AdMob integration and also with
regard to custom parameter
reporting.  That's because now
we have started tracking screens
automatically for you.
So what we will do here is
screen, as users transition from
screen to screen, there are a
couple of things we do for you.
The first is the signal of
transition.  We log a new event
called screen view for you.  It
identifies the screen you are
going to as well as the screen
you came from.  Secondly, this
is context.  Wherever we can as
an Analytics product we want to
augment your reporting by adding
context to your events so, for
example, we had demographics,
locations and interest data.  So
you know who is using your app.
Now we have added screens into
the mix so you have a sense of
where certain actions are taking
place in your app.
This enables us to produce
actually a news report on the
dashboard which breaks down user
engagement in your app by
screen.  Now, you can see where
users are spending time in your
app.  What are the most popular
screens there.  You can segment
this to get down to the lower
grain trends.
You can't talk about dweeper
reporting at least touching on
Data S tudio.  Last year, late
last year we launched beta
reports of our report templates
for Data Studio, and this Data
Studio is an awesome product
that showcases what is possible
when you link your Firebase app
to BigQuery because it
visualizes your raw data and
allows you to fully customize
your own dashboard using the law
data, produce the metrics you
care about in the order you care
about and share them with the
rest of your organization.  I'm
going to give you a walk through
of this in a bit using my own
app so you can see it in action.
use of context to better
understand app actions and
another, someplace, one place
that's especially important to
understand that context is in
regard to a recent launch from
our friends at Android.  That's
Android instant
Android Instant Apps.  The
Android instant Android Instant
App experience is seamless.
It combines the accessibility
of a website with the rich user
experience of a native app.
And because it's so different,
it stands to reason that users
will actually behave differently
in the instant app.  That's
kind of the point.  But in terms
of measurement of instant apps
you need three things.  The
first is you need a high level
overview across your instant app
and installed app of what the
user perform ance and behavior
is like so you can track KPI and
understand from a business
point of view how you are doing.
distinguish between instant app
behavior and installed app
behavior.  Since it's such a new
technology, you need to
understand how instant app
behavior is different for users
as well.  And thirdly, it's very
common for users to graduate
from an instant app to the
installed app.  And when they
do, you want to make sure you
are measuring that person as a
single user rather than two
completely disjoint users.  In
all three ways we have thought
ahead of you and Analytics can
support you in these use cases.
We have put together a
developer guide to help you
think about how you ought to
measure instant apps, and you
request check that out, and if
you are thinking of building an
instant app of your own
business, Firebase has you
covered there.
So that covers for the deeper
reporting section.  Now, I want
to move onto the real time
reporting section.  Google
Analytics launched real time
reporting almost six years ago
and it was ahead of its time and
set the standard for real time
reporting.
So when we set out to build
our own real time reports in
Google Analytics for Firebase,
we already know how users love
to view these reports.  Knowing
what your end users are up to in
your app is i nspiring, and
it's insightful and it had also
critical this real time nature
of it for validation and for
debugging your app.  So we
wanted to set out to build
reporting that satisfied all of
these same use cases and so
earlier this year when we
launched a series of reports to
do so, starting with stream
view.
Stream view gives you a real
time view of your Analytics data
as we collect it.  It's not
just fast.  It's rich.  It's
dynamic.  And it's surprisingly
deep.  You get event location
detail down to the city level
and event data down to the
parameter level, and as you are
exploring and try to understand
how your users are behaving, you
can actually apply these as
filters to find out, for
example, what are u sers in San
Francisco buying or where are
the top players in the world
locate thed.  You can apply a
filter to get at that.
To see the individual journey
of a user, sueser snapshots can
deliver you that.  User
snapshot is like a virtual focus
test.  We visualize the stream
of events coming from a single
device along a time line.  As
you are following this, it's
like your following a user's
progression through the app.
It's like a virtual focus test.
Anyone who has administered a
focus test knows that invariably
your users use product
differently than you think they
do and you will learn something.
I mentioned before about how
we log a screen view event
automatically for you.  You will
see the show appear and the
sequence of screen view events
identifies users path through
the app.  You can see the logs
and the crashes that are logged
if you have integrated crash
reporting.  You will also see ad
impressions and clicks through
our AdMob integration.  We
realize the interface is ideal
for debugging that's why we
built debug view on top of it as
well.  As an app developer m
yself I know how critically
important it is to instrument
your app right the first time.
If you make mistakes in your
tracking and you release that
app version, it will be haunting
you forever sending polluted
data into your Analytics and
there is no way to get rid of
it.  We want to build a tool
that helps you to validate and
get it right and insure that
your data is pristine after you
launch your app.  Debug view
logs events in real time through
your development devices, it
let's you examine every single
event, very parameter you are
sending and if there are any e
rrors in your tracking we don't
hide those.  We log an error
event or parameter along with
the necessary details and links
to help center articles to help
you address that and validate it
before you launch.  The
feedback on this real time
reporting has been awesome so
far.  As an Analytics PM you
don't often get to build
something that inspires emotion
so when you do, you know you
have done something special, and
this one on the top middle I
don't know if you can read it.
It says Ms. Next child will be
called debug view.  I love that
because I named it, so I think
it's a beautiful name and right
now my daughter is relieved at
home because she is not named
debug view Ganem.  Feedback has
been exceptional.  But some of
you told us you need access to
the underlying real time data
from the real time reports.  So
we have made that possible
through integration with
BigQuery.
Now, because the BigQuery
question comes up all of the
time and a lot of you have
questions about how it works, I
will walking you through the
process of linking to BigQuery,
using it and laying the data
Data Studio on top of that.  So
can we switch to the demo,
please?.  So here I'm in
Firebase Console, and I go to my
project settings which is where
I'm at now.  And this is for my
own game project.  And you can
choose here to link to BigQuery.
Here is where you would have
to enter your big information.
Mine is already here.
So I choose to continue and
now I can look at the links to
my data s ets.  Going over to
look at my data set here, you
can see I have one data set for
my Android App and one for my
iOS app.  Each has daily tables
full of data.
So I have 469  days worth of
data in my Android data set but
also this intraday data set.
Intraday meaning these are
events we received throughout
today right up until right now.
So as users are logging events
in my app right now,  they are
being sent in real time from the
back end over to this BigQuery
data set.  And I can run queries
on it.  This is a simple one to
see the list of names of
events.
You can get that.  It's a
pretty simple one, but you can
imagine that you can export this
data, visualize it, combine it
with your own, whatever you
need.  I want to show you a
better way for those of you who
have ideas for how you want to
visualize it but maybe not the
availability or the technical
chops in SQL.  That's why we
built data center integration.
We hand built three pages of
reports here to help you go
deeper with Analytics data.
And these were hand built by
Analytics and Data  Data Studio
PMs and you can apply multiple
filters all at once to go deeper
with this.  So, for example, I
am going to apply a level end,
filter event filter, and maybe
if I want to know what levels my
users are playing I can apply
that.  I see the breakdown of
the school and the roof tops l
evel.  I want to know what
cities users are playing
rooftops because that's my
advanced level.  That's where my
power users are.  I can see
that saw Paul low is extremely
popular which isn't surprising
if you know about the
skateboarding culture.  Here is
how easy it is to customize.  I
could say I don't want events, I
want count of users, and I
don't want city.  I want to look
at app versions and tables are
so boring, I want a pie chart
and I want to change this to app
version.
And just like that, I have
customized it and I can share it
with Russ, show him how hard I
worked to produce this form.
It's that easy and I lot of you
have questions about how e
xpensive is this?  Because
typically working with raw data
is expensive.  Well, Data Studio
is entirely free.  Unlimited
number of reports, sharing,
customization, and, of course,
it queries BigQuery data but
BigQuery has historically
offered 1 terabyte.  For some
apps it would be hard to use
that up in a month, but today
BigQuery has launched a 10
gigabyte per month free storage
tier making this cheap and
affordable to work with raw
data.
All right.  Go back to the
slides.  So that was a lot of
stuff I know we covered but
actually that's not all we are
up to.  I want to invite Krista
to the stage to tell you more.
Krista.
(
Applause).
>> KRISTA SEIDEN: Thank you,
Steve, my name is Krista Seiden
and I'm also a product manager
on Google Analytics or Firebase.
We have just heard from Steve
about a ton of new features just
released in Google Analytics
for Firebase.  I don't know
about you but I'm excited by a
lot of these.  Let's look at how
you can use a lot of these new
f eatures along with core
product functionality to help
you drive growth and attribution
for your businesses.
Now, once you have built and
launched your app, you want to
pay close attention to your
Analytics data to understand how
your app is being used.  You
will also want to understand the
sources of traffic driving
users to your app and determine
your highest value networks and
campaigns for conversion events
such as first open, in app
purchases and more.
An important way to determine
who your best users are is by
understanding their post install
behavior with conversion
events.  So consider what the
drivers for your business are.
Out of the box we mark first
open and in app purchase as
conversion events but every
business is different, every
business is unique, and you are
going to have different events
that might be meaningful for
your business.  So I would
encourage you to go ahead and
mark those events as conversion
events in the UI to unlock
attribution reporting on those
events.  For example, you might
decide that something like an
app update is a really good
signal of user engagement with
your app, so you might want to
mark app updates as a conversion
event to unlock attribution
reporting on app updates.
By doing so, you will have
further visibility into the
various ad networks you are
running campaigns on by seeing
which campaigns are leading to
more engaged higher value user
users.  Simply put conversion
events allow you to focus on the
most valuable events and users
and determine your high value
campaigns driving engagement in
your app.
basics on understanding how
users are finding your app and
what they are doing in there, I
want to talk to you about
attribution.  So we have built
several integrations to help you
grow with a single SDK.
First up, universal app
campaigns.  So you cannot have a
successful mobile app business
without having a successful
growth  strategy and you need to
answer two questions to execute
on that successful growth
strategy.  First, who are the
best customers for your app?
And second, where do you find
them?  Which media channels are
most effective at finding these
customers and getting them to
install and use your app?  And
that can be complex.  So we have
built universal app campaigns
or U AC to help you reach people
across multiple billion user
properties including Google
Play, search, YouTube, Gmail,
and  millions of apps and asites
across the display network.
All you have to do is tell us
the app you would like to
promote, the price you are
willing to pay per install, and
a few more bits of information
like the ad text, the v ideos
and assets, and UAC will then do
the work by using Machine
Learning to deliver the maximum
number of installs at the price
you have specified.
And UAC is now even better.
AdWords has  launched the
ability to launch for higher
value installs.  This means you
are not just optimizing for the
number of installs, but also for
the post install events such as
in app purchase that you have
specified as conversion events
through Firebase.  Now, UAC is
an encriedable  feature in
AdWords that we know will help
you bring high value users to
your app.  Let's say you are a
large marketer or large
developer and you manage and buy
ads programmatically using the
double click zing tall marketing
suite.  That's why I'm excited
to announce that today we have a
new integration with double
click digital marketing.  This
is in beta as of today.
Now, Firebase tracked install
and post install events can
easily be imported back into ZZM
as conversions.  This means
that large advertisers can
seamlessly integrate Firebase to
their overall programmatic
buying, measurement and
optimization needs using club
click. double click.
We know you are not just
advertising with AdWords and
double click.  That's why we are
continually investing in
growing our third party
advertising network.  Today I'm
excited to announce that we have
over 50 ad network partners and
we are continuing to invest in
this area.  We have invested in
integrating with all of these
different pieces to help you
advertise across platforms,
allowing data from all of thighs
to come together in the same
platform to help you make solid
decisions on the data that you
are collecting.  Simply put, we
are creating a single source of
cross network  attribution.
Now that we have covered
attribution, let's focus on
using your Analytics date  data
to drive growth.  Let's look at
a case study.  Who a call is an
app that acts as a caller ID.
The service model is more
passive than most because they
are relying on the frequency for
which users are getting calls.
So instead of focusing on
something like retention rate as
their most important metric,
uninstall rate has become the
most critical metric for whose
call.  To the who's call
starting using the Google
Analytics for Firebase to log
removal of apps automatically
and with BigQuery they were able
to analyze the data in depth.
They soon realized that they had
a first day uninstall rate of
almost 70 peevers.  7 0 % .
That is really bad.  So armed
with this data the who's call
tem started improving the
process of on boarding bit
running AV testsgy getting
people to accept permissions and
keep the app.  What they were
able to do was reduce the
uninstall rate by 14% and
increase retention rate by 6%.
To sum this up, they said that
using Firebase we are able to
consolidate and measure
important metrics within a
unified platform.  It relieves
the burden of data analysis and
allows us to take action where
it really counts.  I think that
this is a really great example
of using your Analytics data to
actually drive growth.
And that data will  help you
to not only understand where
your users are coming from but
will give you insights into
their behavior in your app.
Now, you have been focused on
growing your high value users,
and now you want to retain them.
Using Google Analytics for
Firebase you can identify these
high value audiences and send
these audiences for
re-engagement campaigns.  You
can also use these  audiences
across over areas of Firebase
specifically to target them in
Cloud messaging and remote
config.
Recently we launched a couple
of updates to these targeting
options.  First, logical
audience combinations such as
includes one of.  For example,
you could target audiences that
contain at least one of
purchasers, lifetime value
greater than zero or high
scoring users with an offer for
a free character in the app to
incentivize them to come back.
Second, you can now target using
user properties in Cloud m
essaging and remote  config.
For example, this screen shot
shows high level users.  These
are users at or above level 20
in your app.  Now, you can use
this to customize app experience
of users by different skill
users by leveraging remote
config.  This allows you to get
more con you lar and specific
with targeting options to reach
users you are interested in.
So I have talked about
several ways to understand your
user behavior, drive growth and
attribution with new
integrations and expanded
functionality.  I hope that you
will give some of it a try.
With that, I will hand it back
over to Russ.
(Applause).
>> RUSS KETCHUM: Thanks,
Krista.  So we covered a lot of
ground today.  We introduced you
to our new name, Google
Analytics for friesh we looked
at the core of Analytics and the
enhancements and Krista took us
through how you can use
attribution to drive growth
strategies.  We hope that this
session is the start of a
conversation.  And to keep that
conversation going, there is a
number of other Firebase
sessions  happening throughout
the rest of the I/O.  I would
particularly like to highlight
the session Steve mentioned
earlier, the AdMob and Firebase
better together session that's
happening Friday
morningality at 8:30.  If you
have questions, we will be at
the Firebase Sandbox so you can
find us there and we would love
to hear your thoughts.  With
that, on behalf of the Google
Analytics for Firebase team.
Thank you for coming out and
enjoy the rest of I/O.  Take
care.  (Concluded at 6:39 CT)
>>
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 17, 2017
6:00 PM CT
STAGE 2
FIREBASE ANALYTICS: OVERVIEW
AND UPDATES
T4A422
>>
>> Blank blairchtion.
is Tim Murray and I work on the
Android performance team.  We
will talk about improving your
application's performance on
Android.  Now, one of the big
things that the Android
performance team has done in the
past year was to optimize the
performance of the Google Pixel.
We looked at everything on the
Pixel from application code
down to the kernel, everything
in between.  We tweaked things,
we experimented with things, we
replaced other components
entirely.  What did we try to do
here?  What did we do to, you
know, what was your focus for
performance?
Number one, we wanted to hit
60 frames per second all of the
time.  This means that you have
to render a frame in 16.7
milliseconds all of the time.
If you run at 60 frames per
second your app looks fluid.  It
looks smooth and responsive.
If you don't run at 60 frames
per second people notice.  The
phone doesn't feel fast.  The
phone feels like it's
struggling.
So consistency is parament.
You want to hit 60 frames were
second all of the time.  The
second thing we focused on was
to make applications start
quickly.  A user will switch
between applications a lot in
the course of normal usage.  If
I'm in Gmail and I click a link
that opens in Chrome, I want
that to go quickly.  If I click
a link in Chrome that takes me
to Twitter, I want that to go
quickly too.  Any time I'm
sitting there waiting for the
system to switch applications
feels like dead time.  It's a
time I remember I'm using a
computer as opposed to
interacting with the stuff I
want to get done.
So reducing the amount of
time you spend switching apps
make the system feel effortless.
It's really
important.  That's it.  That's
what we focused on system wide
for Pixel.  We just wanted to
hit those two things
consistently.  If you do these
two things when your device is,
you know, switching between
applications very quickly and
running at 60 frames per second
it will feel fast, but more
importantly, if your device runs
at 60 frames per second and
switches between apps
consistently, it does it all of
the time, the device stops
feeling like anything.  It stops
feeling like a device.  Instead
it feels like you are
interacting directly with the
application.
And that's magical for a
user.  That's really important.
But there is a problem with
this scenario.  We run apps and
apps can be slow.  And, of
course, on the system side of
things, we are constantly trying
to make it easier to write fast
applications and make it harder
to write slow applications, but
as an application developer it
is apples going to be something
you can do to make the system
not run at 60  frames per second
or make your apps start up
really slowly.
The issue is that from the
point of view of the user, they
don't care that it's one app
that happens to run slowly.  One
Health app that doesn't run at
60 fips or doesn't start up
quickly ruins the whole magical
feeling of the device, and it
reminds them they are not i
nteracting with an app, they are
touching their phone and then
they want to throw their phone
against the wall.  So today we
are going to talk about two
tools that we used during Pixel
really extensively to analyze
performance and help you as app
developers figure out what you
can do to improve your
application's performance.
The first tool we are going
to talk about is called
GFXinfo.  It's a shell command
you can use on the device and
all it does is it sells you
about the rendering time for
your application.  So here we
can see that we rendered 223
frames, we got the average
frame time.  The 99th percentile
frame time and it
gives us some idea why it's
actually slow.  We use this
internally and you look at
average frame time, 95th and
99th percentile frame time.
That's all this tool does.  It
doesn't tell you why your app
ran slow.
It doesn't tell you snig you
should do to fix it so why am I
up here talking about it?
Because you can automate
it.  If you take one thing away
from this talk, if you decide
to take a nap for the next half
h our, just run GFXinfo at the
very end of whatever automated
test you are running and
congratulations now you have a
performance test.  Now you have
a thing you can run regressions
on, you can spot regressions in
your application.
The first time you have a
performance regression in your
application that you want to
track down, this will save you
so much time and effort, it will
pay for itself instantly.  This
is how most of the internal
Android yank tests work, this is
how we track all rchg  jarchg
across the system.  Please do
it, it you will say yourself so
much t ime.  But that's GFXinfo.
That only tells you where your
performance is today.  It
doesn't tell you why your
performance is that way or what
you should do about it.
For that we turn to a
different tool, my favorite
tool, the only tool I ever use,
tion systrace.  So a lot of
developers have tried systrace
and they have told me they have
no idea what's going on when
they look at systrace, and
that's fair.  I can stand up
here and tell you that systrace
is easy, it's not really easy.
Systrace is not a CPU p rofiler.
Systrace is instead a system
wide tracing tool.
The first thing that means is
systrace doesn't care about
your app.  It doesn't do
anything special to your
application.  It's not going to
go peek at your  application's
call stacks and say you spent a
really long time in this
function.  It doesn't do that.
It just tells you when your
application was running and
certain events that occur within
your application.  It also
tells you everything about the
rest of the s ystem.  It will
tell you things about the
kernel.  It will tell you things
about the graphics pipeline.
It will tell you things  about
the framework and activity
manager and things like that.
there is any information you
want about afternoon Android
device, we have probably
surfaced it via systrace.  We
use it for everything.  Just to
be, just to reinforce how
important systrace is, in the
past year, I have looked at
somewhere over 2,000 traces.  We
use systrace a whole lot.  Now,
systrace is not arch Android
studio.  If you want to get
systrace, there are two ways to
get it.  First of all, it's in
platform tools in the Android
SDK.  You can get a version of
systrace from there.  What I
like to do though is I get
systrace from the repository
where it's developed.  It's part
of a project called catapult,
which is on GitHub, catapult it
owned by members of the Google
Chrome and Android teams.
So upstream catapult is
always improving.  I usually get
top of tree catapult.  Once you
get that, you will have this
Python executable that you can
run and you can get a trace.
Now, how does systrace actually
work?  What does it actually
tell you?  Systrace is three
components.  At the bottom is
this thing called F trace.
Ftrace is a Linux kernel feature
that allows the kernel and user
space to write event
information into a sent central
buffer.
What this means basically is
that you can get a journal of
any event that happened on the
system.  So the kernel will tell
us things like, hey, this
process started running on this
CPU, or, hey, the clocks changed
on this CPU.  That's great.
It's really low level, but we
can use it.
The next thing above Ftrace
is a program called
Atrace, Atrace is an Android
program on the device installed
automatically and the Android
image.  It's on every device.
All it does is configure Ftrace,
but it also configures user
space tracing.  So Atrace will
go and turn on all of these
different trace points inside of
the Android user space.
So here we can get things
like do you want to find out
what window manager thought
about your application.  Atrace
will turn that on or activity
manager or any other part of the
Android framework.  All of that
is controlled by Atrace.  The
top most layer is systrace
itself.  Systrace then lives on
your host development machine
and it gets the results from
Atrace, and it wraps those
results in a nice HTML file.
You get this giant to pen
that willly 10s of Megs or even
100s of Megs HTML file that
contains a trace.  It's pretty
convenient and it actually makes
sharing traces incredibly easy.
should do when you decide to
start tracing a device is you
should look at the categories
available on that device.
Systrace events are separated
into categories.  And those
categories will vary from Os
version to Os version and
potentially device to device.
In general, the important
stuff will always be there.  The
Core stuff that you want as an
app developer, we have tests for
that to go beyond every device.
Now, let's actually run a
trace and see what that would
look like.  So this is the
demand I used for the trace you
will see for the rest of this
talk, and the way systrace works
is you provide the list of
event tags that you want in your
trace and here
we have Sched, we have Freq for
CPU frequency information, idle
will tell us when the CPU goes
idle, AM and WM tell us about
the Android activity manager and
window manager.  GFX will tell
us everything you wanted to nose
about the Android graphics
pipeline, view will tell you
about the view hierarchy inside
applications, Dalvik enables the
trace point for the art VM,
input will tell you when you are
actually touching the screen
and binder driver will tell you
exactly when a process is making
an IPC over binder to another
process.  The last three
arguments are s pecial -- key
see we are going to run the
trace for five seconds.  If you
omit the dash key, systrace will
prompt you to prescienter.  Dsh
O, you will right to HTML.  Dsh
B is a little odd.  So I
mentioned Ftrace and the Ftrace
buffer, the Ftrace buffer is a
fixed size.  By default it's
1.4-megabytes and what happens
if you fill this buffer, if you
have too many events for the
buffer is you will get a trace
and then at the end, things will
stop happening.  You think you
ran the trace for five seconds
but maybe you only have 3.5
seconds worth of events in
there.
When I take a trace, I always
increase the buffer size so
here I have increased it to
16-megabytes and for this kind
of trace we probably don't have
to increase the buffer size, but
it's always better to increase
the buffer size and not have to
take a trace a second time than
be overly conservative with the
buffer size.  All right.  We run
this, we now get a trace.  What
does the trace actually look
like?  There is a lot going on
in this trace.  And if you are
in the back, I'm sorry, it's
probably hard to see.
The first thing to know about
the trace is that it is a
timeline view.  It moves left to
right, and you can scroll it
left to right and time moves
from left to right.  So the left
side is the beginning of the
trace.  That's zero seconds
being kicked off the trace and
five seconds is when the trace
ends.  You can move around the
trace.  You can move, you can
pan in time with AMD keys, and
you can zoom in and out on
whatever section of the trace
you are looking at with WS.  So
it's j ust, you know, like a
first person shooter.  The trace
also scrolls up and down.  So
here you see there are a bunch
of rows up here.  There is this
kernel section and a calculator
section.
There are way more rows on
the screen because there is one
row generally for every thread
that is run during the trace.
So you may have hundreds or
thousands of rows in your trace.
The next thing to look at when
you start using systrace is
there is this pallet of tools I
have in the upper right-hand
corner.  You can click on the
tools you can access them with
numbers 1-4.  Number one is the
pointer.  That's the main tool
we will use when we use sis
straes.  That lets us click the
individual events we see in the
trace and get information about
them.
When you click an event it
will show up in the bottom half
of the screen like that.  So
here we could see calculator was
running.  We see the process
ID.  We see the thread ID.  The
priority.  We can see when
exactly it started in the trace.
We see how long it ran for.
We get a bunch of useful
statistics.  You can use a
pointer to select a lot of
different things in the trace
which gives you an aggregate
view chai looks like that.
-- that looks like that.  So
this will basically add up all
of the threads, like if I select
the, a region in the kernel
section, this will add up all of
the threads that occurred and
tell us how much time did we
spend on each thread.  What was
the average time that each
thread ran, things like that.
That's really useful.  We
will come back to that later.
Number two and three, on the
pallet are for panning and
zooming so they are equivalent
to WASD.  You don't need to use
them.  You can use them if you
want.  I generally use WASD.
The fourth tool is incredibly
useful.  It is the highlighter
tool.
So you could select a region
of time in the trace, and that
region will have a white
background and everything you
haven't selected will then have
a gray background.  You can use
this to keep track of the area
you care about as you scroll
vertically through a trace.  So
if you find something in one
process and you think something
went wrong here what else was
the system  doing, you can
scroll up and down the trace and
know exactly what part of the
trace you should be looking at.
I use the highlighter
constantly.  If you start using
systrace, you probably will as
well.
Now, let's scroll down and
see what else is in the trace.
More stuff.  So every row in a
trace is either a counter or a
thread.  And down here at the
bottom is a thread.  These
blocks right here are the Core
thing that you will look at in
systrace.  These are events.  So
every systrace event has a
beginning and an
end.    Systrace events can
then be nested so this is a
stack that grows down.  You can
see that here a choreographer
event happened and a traversal
event was contained entirely
within that event and more
things happened beneath.  This
is some stuff that's part of
calculator app start up.  And
you will see a lot of these as
you look through a trace.  Each
event corresponds to explicit
placed in the Android code base
that somebody thought, hey,
maybe somebody will need to
figure out that this is
happening sometime.  It's good
to pay attention to these.
Now, let's zoom in at the
beginning or at the end of
activity start.  So in this
trace we launched calculator and
clicked a few buttons.  Here we
are at the end of activity
start.  And I do you meaned in
really closely and it's still
probably hard to see because
systrace has a lot of very small
UI elements.  But is there are
these colored bars on top of the
UI thread here.  These colored
bars represent the state of that
thread at any point in time.
There are five different states
that a thread can be in.  Now,
if we click the green bar above
the UI thread in the middle, we
see that at this point the
thread was running.
So at this point, the thread
is actually running on a CPU.
It's running on CPU one, and if
we were to scroll back up to the
kernel section, you will see
it's scheduled on CPU one.  This
is how you can know that our
application is actually run at
particular times on the C PU.
The next state that we care
about is runnable.  Runnable
means that your thread could
start running at some point in
time.  Nothing is preventing
your thread from running.  It's
just that the kernel has not
scheduled it yet.  There are any
number of reasons why this
could happen.  Maybe there is
more higher priority work.
Maybe your thread has just run
for a really long time and the
scheduler is trying to be fair
and give other threads an
opportunity to run.
There are lots of reasons for
this.  If you are seeing a lot
of this in your application,
it's probably due to thread
priority.  The third thing that
you can see on the right-hand
side of the trace here is there
is a red bar.  And the red bar
is uninterruptible sleep which
sounds a little scarier than it
is.  Uninterruptible sleep is
your thread is blocked on some
lock inside of the kernel.
As an application developer,
there is generally not too much
you can do with this.  Sometimes
it's hardware related,
sometimes it has to do with
memory.  Usually if you see a
lot of ininterruptable sleep,
it's my fault.  It's a system
problem.  So we are  probably
aware and trying to fix it, but
sometimes you can see it's
related to memory.  You can get
more information about it.
The fourth type of state is a
special kind of uninterruptible
sleep that as an application
developer you can actually do
something about.  The orange
state here is your thread is
sleeping on block I/O.  This
means that your thread is
reading from disk and the disk
hasn't got be the results back
to your thread, so your thread
can't make progress.  If you see
a lot of this in your  trace,
you are reading too much data.
Try not to read so much data.
The fifth state, the last
state is the state you will see
most often and it's usually
white or gray depending on the
trace.  It means the thread is
sleeping.  The thread has no
work to do so it is asleep.
It's not running.  The scheduler
isn't trying to run it.
Nothing is working on behalf of
the thread directly in the
kernel or anything like that.
If you see this a lot and you
think that's weird, it's
probably due to some user space
lock interaction because user
space locks will show up as
sleeping.
with these colored bars that is
really great is you can select
all of them in a region that you
care about to get aggregate
information.  Here you can see
we spent so much time sleeping
versus runnable versus running.
I do this constantly.  This
gives me a coarse idea 6  of
what the bottleneck is for a
particular piece of code.  I can
take a trace and see, hey, this
thread is running.  It's on the
C PU.  It should be making
progress, but it's taking too
long.  What's going on?
It means that it just has too
much CPU work to do.  If it's
getting CPU time and not running
fast enough all you can do is
reduce the amount of CPU work it
has to do.  If I take a trace
and see that a thread is always
in block I/O.  I
know it's reading too much data
from disk.  So don't read so
much data from disk.
If you are sleeping where you
don't expect, it probably means
that your application logic is
a little weird somewhere.  You
probably have some weird
priority inversion something or
lock intention that you didn't
expect, something like that.
Another useful tool on a trace
is I mentioned the input tag
earlier.  And up  here at the
very top, there is this tiny
little box for input response,
and this shows where I actually
touched the screen in the trace.
So here I touched the screen
and I guess my finger was down
for 28.8 milliseconds.
You can use that in the trace
similar to the highlighter.
You can use that to orient
yourself in the trace.  You know
what's going on if you remember
what you were doing while
creating the  trace, you can
figure out where exactly you are
logically inside that trace.
Well, what if you need more
information?  What if you have a
lot of information about what
your app is doing logically that
you want to get in a trace?
Good news.  That's  pretty easy.
There is a class, A ndroid.OS.
trace that has two methods,
beginning section and end
session.  You can put a string
in begin section and that will
show up as an event in the
trace.  It shows up the same as
anything else.
The only special thing you
need to keep in mind here is you
need to call trace.end section
from the same thread every time
you have a begin section.  If
you don't have a one to one
mapping between begin section
and end section your trace will
look word.  You will wet very
weird rendering in your trace
and it's just because you forgot
end section or you had too many
end sections.
If we take a trace and we
want to see the app events we
have to do a little bit more
than we did initially.  First,
we need to specify this app tag
as part of the arguments to the
trace, and then we have to pass
dash A and the package name that
you care about.  Then you just
take a normal trace like that,
and you open it up, and you see
this trace event, which is just
whatever you put in your string.
If you have logical groupings
of work or a logical task that
the user is doing, a dding a
straes event for that is really
useful.
When I look at large complex
applications within Google, I
find that the applications I can
debug easily, and understand
the performance of easily are
the ones that implement their
own application trace events.  I
definitely recommend doing it.
It's not that difficult and it
will be worth it as you start
looking at systrace.  It will
make systrace a lot more
comprehensible.
And for reading a trace,
that's about it.  There is not
really that much going on in a
trace.  It's just sort of what
the system is doing at any point
in time.  And everything that
in time ends up looking like
this.  So now what?  I don't
think most of you probably feel
that comfortable using systrace
yet so why would we want to use
systrace?  What does systrace
tell us that makes it says
useful.
Let's go back to the two
goals we had for people  Pixel,
number one 60 frames pr second,
number two makes app start
quickly.    Systrace could tell
us about this directly, but
there is an underlying principle
we should call out.
Don't look slow.  That's it.
That's really the only
performance rule there is.  The
reason why we use systrace is it
can tell us where we look slow
and note that I said don't look
slow.  I didn't say don't be
slow.  This may sound weird
coming from a person who works
on performance, but for any
moderately complex application,
at some point in time, you are
going to have to do something
that is slow.
Maybe you are going to do
some giant matrix multiply for
some reason, maybe you are going
to read from disk, you have to
read a large image, maybe you
have to talk to the network
which could take who knows how
long.  At that point, you want
to understand why did the system
end up looking slow when I was
doing this?  And then what can I
do to washing around this?
You know you have to do the
slow thing, what can you do in
your application to identify
where exactly that slow point
happened and then work around it
to make the system still look
fast because that's all the user
cares about.  They don't care
if the system is slow soar is
fast.  They just want the system
to feel fast.  If you do that,
it will
be great.
Now, let's apply that to the
two goals that we
have.  App start up, the basic
thing with systrace and app
start up you can use systrace to
figure out exactly where your
time is going during app start
up and then you can decide what
to do about it.  There is no one
size fits all advice here.  You
have to understand what your
particular application is doing,
what is needs of your
application are, and then you
can come up with a
solution.  The first thing we
use systrace for to analyze app
start up is inflation.
Here we have this inflate
section in a trace.  This is
from the very beginning of
calculator from activity start
in calculator.  And we have this
really long inflate section,
but more importantly we can see
the exact cost of inflating
every view for calculator.  This
is really u seful to help you
figure out the cost of a view
hierarchy or  changing a view
hierarchy.  You can say is it
actually worth 50 milliseconds
to inflate these views right
now?  Could I do this later?
Could I do something else
instead?  You have to come up
with whatever solution is right
for your application but
systrace can help you figure out
what is happening today in your
application.
So you can come up with those
improvements and ideas for
future changes to your
app.  Another thing that
systrace tells you is you can
tell exactly when
applications start up ended from
the user point of view.  There
is more than bind application
activity start and application
start up.  Here you can see the
UI thread and render thread of
the application which are the
two most important threads in
making your application run at
60 frames per second, and we
know that once those threads
have finished for the first
time, here you can see the UI
thread running and finishing
this choreographer frame along
with the render thread running
at the same time.  Once that's
done the app is loaded and ready
for user input.  At that point
from the user's point of view,
app startup is done.
systrace is the resource tag,
res.  So you can look at exactly
what resources you are loading
in your application at any point
in time.  Usually loading
resources is
not a huge deal.  Occasionally
we have seen areas where
resource loading can be e
xpensive.  It's worth checking
in your application.  It will
tell you just as the name of an
event exactly what resource you
are loading and how long it
takes.  And, again, you can
figure out is it worth loading
this resource right now?
All right.  Let's move to
jank because that's the fun one.
Fixing jank with systrace is a
two accept process.  You need
to figure out where the jank
actually happens because maybe
you can spot every time the
system doesn't run at 60 per
second, but I have been doing
this full time for a while now,
I can't even do that.  So
systrace can help make it really
obvious where exactly you
dropped a frame.  The second
step that you use systrace for
is working your way backwards
from the dropped frame to what
actually went wrong, and then
you can figure out what to do
about it.  So here we have a UI
thread and render thread again
in an application, and we are
running the thread or the
application normally, it's not a
janky frame it's just normal 60
frame per second rendering.
The UI thread is the main
application thread.  That's what
actually g ets, you know, input
events from system server.
Render thread actually gets
information from the UI thread
and sends that to the GPU.  This
means that in order to display
a frame on time, the UI thread
and the render thread have to
complete within 16.7
milliseconds every time.  This
gives sis rase a nice kind of
rhythm.  You can get used to
this rhythm when you open a
systrace and say, oh, yes, I
dropped a frame there because
you can tell it didn't quite
line up.  It makes it easy to
spot where the UI pipeline
didn't run at a full 60 frames
per second once you get used to
this.
Now, if that's not
enough, you can look at surface,
we don't have time to go
through the full pipeline but
the high level overview is your
Apple run a frame and it will
send the frame to surface
slinger.  Surface slinger will
take whatever app is rendering
on the screen and it will
combine that with the navigation
bar and the status bar and
actually send the resulting full
complete the composited frame
to the display to show up on the
screen.
What this means is that
surface slinger is the central
source of truth.  If surface
slinger thinks you hit your
frame  deadline, you are running
at 60 frames were second.  If
surface slinger says you didn't
deliver a frame you know you
didn't hit 60 frames per second
and here the way we can do that
is we have a counter here.
There is one counter here per
application in a trace.  This
counter here is alternating
between zero and one for how
many frames the surface slinger
have from this application that
are ready to be displayed.
So you know that if the
counter goes to zero for more
than 16 milliseconds, you have
definitely missed a frame.  This
is the ultimate way to know
whether you had jank in your
application or not.
This gets us, this helps us
spot where the problem is.  It
helps us know where you actually
dropped the frame.  So what do
you do when you know where the
problem is and you are going to
work your way backwards?  So we
are going to look at surface
slinger to work your way
backwards.  We are looking at
surface slinger as an example of
a relatively simple chain here
because application chains can
be more complicated.  We don't
quite have time.
But usually you want to know
why something woke up.  So we
have a running state in the
application, and we want to know
what made it r unnable because
that will tell us why the thread
woke up in the first place.  So
here I click the running state
on top of surface slinger and I
can look at the left arrow and
see the runnable state.
Now, I have the runnable
state selected and I want to go
ahead and highlight that.  You
can highlight anything you
currently have selected with the
M key.
Now, we have a nice little
bar showing what we are looking
at on the trace.  In this
runnable section, we have an
additional argument at the
bottom here.  It says wake up
from TID529.  This means that
the surface slinger thread was
triggered by thread 529.  Now, I
don't know what thread 529 is,
but I do know that thread 529
must be running at this point
because if thread 529 wasn't
running it couldn't have woken
up surface slinger.  So I can
scroll back up to the top of the
trace to see what is actually
running on the CPU.  And I see
this thing event thread.
So I will click event thread.
And event thread is part of
surface slinger.  It's another
thread inside of the surface
slinger process.  And now I want
to know what woke up that event
thread because I'm w orking my
way backwards from, to figure
out why surface slinger woke up
at all here.  So I will scroll
back down and find event thread
inside of surface slinger and
there is the actual thread state
for the event thread.  We just
had that little colored bar to
show it's running because it
doesn't have any events during
that time.  We can click the
runnable section of the event
thread and see that it woke up
from thread 4568.  Now, I
cheated.  I know I what thread
4568 is.  It's the display sync
thread that is also in surface
slinger.  Let's go to that one
and see what woke up the display
sync thread.  That's right down
there.
We click it.  We see wake up
from TID zero.  TID zero is a
special thing in a trace and is
it, all it means is that
whatever thread you are looking
at was woken up by an interrupt
of some sort.  It was woken up
by an interrupt handler.
Usually this means a timer
expired.  This makes sense for
surface slinger.  Surface
slinger will run every 16
milliseconds so a timer expired.
Woke up this display
synchronization thread which in
turn woke up the event thread
which woke up surface slinger.
If you see this in your trace
it usually means that some
timer expired and woke up your
thread and that's why you are
running.  And that's it.  That's
the basics of what you need to
know to actually get somewhere
with systrace.  Take some traces
of your application and just
try to see what's going on.
Look at the system.  Look at how
frames are being drawn, and
sent to the display and how you
are getting touch input from the
server.
This kind of tracing
backwards via the runnable state
is most of what we do to
understand how the system fits
together.  And you can use it to
improve your applications as
well.
Now, if you want a lot more
advice on what you should do as
opposed to how to understand
what's going on today, I
recommend you go to the, there
is an additional Android
performance talk on the UI
pipeline that Chet Haas and
Chris crake are giving Friday at
1:30.  So go to that.  Know
they will talk about recycler
view and optimizations there
which is always a popular topic.
So that's it.  Thank you.
(Applause).
(Concluded at 7:38CT).
>
SAN JOSE, CALIFORNIA
MAY 17, 2017
7:00 PM CT
STAGE 2
ANDROID PERFORMANCE: AN
OVERVIEW
TE94CD
Services Provided By:
Caption First, Inc.
P.O. Box 3066
Monument, CO 80132
800-825-5234
Www.captionfirst.com
This text is being provided
in a rough draft format.
Communication Access Realtime
Translation (CART) is provided
in order to facilitate
communication accessibility and
may not be a totally verbatim
record of the proceedings.
* * *
>>
welcome to the AMP keynote in
Google I/O 2017.  If you have
gob all the way you have made it
to the fourth keynote so while
we can't guarantee you this will
be the most exciting one we can
guarantee it will be the
fastest because we are the AMP
team.  We are, Chen Shay, Elena
Legeros and I'm Malte Ubl.  So
thanks for coming.  So what is
AMP?  In a nutshell, open source
project for creating super fast
Web pages.  Behave been around
for a while and wanted to give
you a quick year view of how
things started.
>> So AMP was release the as
a developer preview in October
2015 and then in February 2016
for the first time it was
released to consumers as the AMP
top stories carousel on Google
Search.  You might have seen
this before.  There is this
contrary row sell and you type
it, apps instantly, you can
swipe through the stuff.  So
this was the first time AMP came
to users.  Later that year in
the summer of 2016 we announced
a project alled AMP adds that we
are going to talk about later
today.  Then in September of
that year,
AMP became eligible for all
Google Search results in 2017 we
had the first ever AMP
conference, if you haven't been
there, you should come to the
next one.  It was really nice
and today I'm excited to
announce that the top service
carousel that used to be only
available in some countries is
available worldwide in every
single country where Google
Search is serving Web traffic.
(Applause).
we want to talk about today is
AMP across publishing and
platforms.  The topic we are
most excited about now, AMP and
eCommerce.  Since progressive
Web  Web Apps are a thing at I/O
we want to talk about how they
relate to AMP.  We will be open
with the challenges the project
is facing and how we are
addressing them and finally we
will talk about AMP adds.  Let's
take a little bit of time to
talk about why AMP is a thing.
What we found is that Web pages
sometimes load slowly on 3G we
are seeing an average of 19
ekdz.
Every second of load time
conversion rates drop by 7%.
Similarly bandwidth is a problem
with mobile.  There are some
countries where a megabyte of
data might cost up to 5% of a
person's monthly wage.  On the
other hand, we see for aim AMPs
using almost a megabyte of data
and that cannot work as an
economic model.  It doesn't fit
together.  So this can be
summarized as the Web not
meeting user expectations.
That's really where AMP comes
in.  We want to get in line
with those user expectations.
So what is AMP doing to fix it?
A year ago I was on stage here
and I announced this metric
which was nice.  What we are
seeing is that loaded from
Google Search, AMP pages were
loading at the Median in under
one second and that's a good
number.  It's nice to see that
this is actually remained
consistent as the corpus of AMP
pages has been growing
tremendously, but I'm very
excited to announce that as of
this week we are launching an
advancement that will make all
AMP pages across this large
corpus get twice as fast.  The
metric we are
optimizing --
(Applause).
Is the first
contentful.  So that's the
first time the browser draws
something that's interesting.
For a news article, for example,
that would be the text.  We
have done other things to
optimize performance.  Many Web
pages use the typical average
Web page 60% of the bytes for
images.  We have managed to
reduce byte usage across this
entire corpus by 50%.  So this
is done using compression, but
at a level where it doesn't have
visual impact and, for example,
for P and Gs, there is no
visual difference.  It's just
metadata removed.  So across
this wide corpus we are getting
50% less bytes so thinking back
for, you know, that data might
be expensive, I think this is
really, really good for users.
>> Similarly, you mise have
heard about a thing called broad
leaf.  It's swies bread and the
name of a new compression
standard Google securic which is
better than the nominal
standard that probably all of
you are hopefully using.  We
have activated this for the
Google M cache for all
documents.  What we are seeing
now is a 10 fears reduction in
bytes for documents.  And we
think we can do a little bit
better over the next weeks or,
so but I think it's a great
first step.  So this is what we
were doing in terms of
performance.  I want to ask
Elena Legeros on stage to talk
about AMP traction across
content publishers.
>> ELENA LEGEROS: Thanks so
much Malte Ubl.  Wow!  This is
my very first I/O and I am super
excited to be here.  Over the
past year and a half, I have had
the opportunity to work with a
lot of publishers and talk to
them about their experiences on
AMP.  And I have heard their u
ps and their downs, and talked
to them about both their
successes and their challenges.
Overall, I have gotten the
message that AMP is really
working for publishers.  So just
for some context, since launch,
publishers have created over 2
billion AMP documents across
more than 900,000 domains.  Up
to 35 million AMP documents are
created across more than 200
countries and in more than 100
languages every week.  Every
second 58 AMP pages are released
into the wild.  That's
significant.
And while we continue to see
a lot of new news publishers
adopting AMP or creating AMP
pages for their websites, we are
really enthusiastic about the
traction among other areas like
eCommerce and travel and food
and other diverse categories of
websites from around the world.
When
we first or when AMP first
launched, publishers wanted to
know why they should devote
their resources to building AMP
pages for their websites.  They
understood that AMP was fast.
That was  really plain to see.
But they wanted to know what
they were going to get out of
it.  So I want to take a few
minutes to show a few examples
of what a few publishers have
gotten out of AMP, just a few
successes.  First, The Weather
Channel has seen a 4X increase
in click through rates on AMP
articles into their main site up
from 21% to 90% since launching
at the beginning of the year.
Having instant access to
information like where to expect
golf-ball sized hail like the
hail seen in this screen shot,
is really valuable to people.
And The Weather Channel gets
that.  And AMP is clearly paying
off for them.
resource for -- Terra offered
information to people across
Spain, and the U.S.  After
ilding AMP pages for their
websites they saw people
spending twice as much time on
air AMP pages compared to their
regular mobile pages.  They also
so you a 33% increase on click
through rates on ads.
That's
huge.  And the Singapore-based
Wigo.com is the largest travel
marketplace in the Middle East
and Asia Pacific helping people
compare travel costs from
hundreds of global and local
partners.  She created AMP
versions of landing pages that
were designed to support popular
search queries like cheap
flights from Singapore to
Bangkok.
And what they found was that
conversion rates to partner
sites went up 95%.  And search
to conversion rates improved by
49% which completely validated
their effort.  So we have been
really impressed by the success
publishers have seen on AMP, and
we keep hearing more and more
stories like these.
So far we have talked about
the amazing growth of publishers
and the performance they have
seen on AMP.  Another critical
component of AMP is that it is
open to all platforms on the
Internet.  And already a lot of
platforms are supporting AMP.
We have seen  adoption from
search engines to mobile apps
and there they are an essential
part of the AMP community, bing,
Pinterest and linked in or
linking to aim pages and
pointing users to a great,
consistently fast experience.
And recently a few new
platforms joined the AMP family
which we are excited about.
Yahoo! Japan as well as China's
largest search engines, Sogo and
Baidu are all connecting to AMP
pages from their search r
esults bringing over a billion
people across Asia a faster Web
experience.
AMP has gone social in China.
10-cents Q zone as well as
Weibo, the top two social
networking platforms in China
are bringing the benefits of the
AMP experience to their
hundreds of millions of monthly
active users.  Q zone and Weabu
together with baidu and Sogo
will enable almost all of the
mobile Internet users in China
to experience the speed of  AMP.
social platform a little closer
to home, we are thrilled to
share that in the coming weeks,
Tumblr is rolling out support
for AMP on more than 340 million
of their blog
pages.  But those aren't all of
our announcements.  Nothing is
more important to Twitter than
getting users to the content
that they are looking to reach
quickly.  They were an early
supporter of the AMP project l
aunching in their moments
product in 2016.  And we are
thrilled to announce that
Twitter is rolling out support
to the full feed on mobile Web
and on their Android and iOS
native apps bringing the
benefit, all of the benefits of
AMP to the world of social
discovery.
It's so encouraging to see
platforms from around the world
embracing AMP like this because,
again, AMP is all about a
community coming together and
working together to improve the
mobile Web for everyone.  And
with that, I will pass it to
Chen Shay.
(Applause).
>> CHEN SHAY: Hey, everyone!
We are happy to announce that
AMP is open for business.  Now,
when AMP first started, we
targeted news publishers, but
over the last year, we have seen
a wide adoption of AMP across a
variety of different verticals
from recipes to health to
dictionaries, and as we were
looking at all of these AMP
documents, we realizes that
while AMP is great for reading
the news, AMP is even better for
shopping on the Internet
because AMP is focused on speed
and performance and shoppers are
won and lost in the span of a
second.
You see, it wasn't that long
ago when I was a new mom, and I
was really struggling to figure
out my new life and to put
things nicely, I really didn't
have it together.  I spent the
first few weeks in my house in
my pajamas, did not know how to
make things work.
But I was lucky to be able to
make all of my purchases online
on my mobile phone, everything
from ordering diapers to booking
plane tickets to see family to
buying food on line.  But the
thing is it had to be done very
quickly because if my baby woke
up and started crying, I put my
phone away, right?  And then I
would probably get back to the
purchase, but maybe another day,
maybe another week.  And more
and more people are finding
themselves in situations like
mine making quick mobile, making
quick purchases on their mobile
phones whether it's in between
meetings or while computing on a
train or maybe while sitting
here at Google I/O at the AMP
keynote.
In fact, Forbes reported that
this year half of all of
eCommerce revenue will come from
mobile.  And when we are doing
things on our mobile phones, we
have constant interruptions.  We
have babies, we have
colleagues, we have a horrible
Internet connection.  And we
don't have time to wait for
things to load.
That's why speed and
performance is so important.
Now, alley express agrees.  They
reported that when they reduce
their load time by 36%, they
were able to increase their
orders by 10.5% and able to
increase their conversion rates
by 27.5%.  People just want
their lives made easier.  And
that's why it's important for us
to focus on speed and
performance so that we can help
make people's lives easier.  And
this is where AMP comes in.
So last year AMP was not
ready for eDmers, but things are
now changing and a few months
ago, we introduced AMP form
where you can use to search for
items or add items to a shopping
cart.  And today we invite you
to try out AMP bind, the key
ingredient for eCommerce and
AMP.  Amp-Bind allows you to add
custom interactivity
to your website.  So you can do
things like refine an image
gallery by color.  You can
choose a green apple or red
delicious.  You can update your
product prices based on the size
of the products.  And you can
tap on a button to show more
items like we do here.
And the cool things that
happening is that to show these
more items, we are bringing them
via a server call without
reloading the page.  And you can
use the same exact mechanic to
show search results or filter or
path  paginate or short a page.
What this means is that it's
possible for eCommerce sites to
use AMP and to get to parity
with their conical pages.  And
we have new e Commerce features
coming out every single week
from dynamic form validation to
payments and currently we are
working on auto complete and
getting it out the door.  So if
you want to see code samples for
eCommerce with AMP go AMP by
example.com sls eCommerce and to
start playing with Amp-Bind go
to bitly/amp-Bind.  We have eBay
and Alibaba, and they are all
building super fast shopping
experiences for their users with
AMP.  Alle express reported
that they saw a 4% uplift in
conversion via AMP.  And
Zalando which is one of the top
fashion e Commerce retailers in
Europe, they have been rolling
out AMP for their product detail
pages.  And finally, eBay, eBay
believed early on that AMP
clearly aligns with their Core
strategy, and they were one of
the first eCommerce sites to bet
on AMP in a big way.  Last
summer they launched all of
their product listing pages with
AMP.  And today we are happy to
announce that eBay is launching
all of their product pages
worldwide on AMP.
And they will go live this
summer.  This is going to enable
users to search for a product
on Google and buy it on eBay in
mere mily  milliseconds.  So if
you want to learn more about
eCommerce and AMP we have a
dedicated session to just this
topic and you are welcome to
join us Friday at 3:30 on stage
6.  Now, I would like to welcome
Malte Ubl back to the stage to
talk to you about progressive
Web Apps.
(Applause).
>> MALTE UBL: Yes, let's
talk about PWA in AMP.  Who has
heard about PWA already?  Almost
everyone.  So but let's still
take a quick look like what
progressive Web Apps are.  They
are bringing a bunch of new
features to the Web platform
that used to be a thing you only
find on native things like push
notifications, offline support,
ability to add your Web App to
the home stream just like a
native app and access to easy
payments.  There is more stuff
but those are the most important
ones.  What they are bringing
is the long-term engagement that
you would  otherwise only find
in native apps together with the
d iscoverability of Web apps.
I work for Google, we built the
search engine and enables people
to come to websites.  It works
well.  And people have found
that it's not as easy to get
someone to install an app.  PW
As bring this together and make
a good business case.
Now, this is kind of where
AMP comes in, because PWAs rely
on the technology call service
workers.  They are
transferringly installed when
you first go to PWA.  There is
the first time the user
experience may not be as fast
yet because you don't have the
service worker installed.  Now,
last year here at Google I/O,
Alex Russell who is the inventor
the PWA in general coined the
term start fast stay fast.
That's what AMP is doing.  So if
you build AMP pages and have
the AMP pages install the
service worker you have this
continuous awesome user
experience where the first
contact with the brand is
through the AMP page and it
loads in an instant and from
there you go on and have the
awesome engagement features of
PWAs.
That was last year.  We have
consistently improved this
experience.  By the way, it's
kind of an an no gram..  Awesome
contribution from the Internet.
So what we have done is we
have built infrastructure that
makes it really easy to build
your PWA based on your AMP
pages.  It turns out it works
well.  It's great for users to
get the first AMP load time
experience and then your amazing
PWA for subsequent visits, but
it's also great for business
because it turns out that with
this approach you can invest in
AMP today and then make that
count for your investment in
your PWA in the future.  So
basically our message is i t's.
>> bad to go AMP in today
because you want to have a PWA
but it's a longer term boat but
those are paying into the same
destination.  So this is kind of
how the user flow works.  User
discovers content, so they might
search for it on Google or as
we referred earlier today from
Elena Legeros, Twitter will
start linking to AMP  content
across the apps.  They click, it
loads super fast because it's
an AMP page.  The AMP page
installs the service worker in
the background silently and
every next click is getting the
user into your PWA experience.
There is a few companies out
there who have already done
this.  Shirt example, Zing,
German business social network,
they launched a PWA amp combo,
so you might search for a job on
Google which we have learned
today is now more of a thing
even, and you come to their
landing page.  That's an AMP
page.  It loads in an instant,
installs the service w orker and
any click that gets you more
into the funnel to get the job
is driven by the PWA service
worker and is super fast.
Rock den which is a Japanese
site launched this for the
recipe site and they were seeing
great metrics.  The time spent
for users going through the AMP
funnel up by 50% and the CTR
from the landing page down into
the other recipes which is
really I think the thing they
are driving went up by 3.6%.
Now, I only scratched the
surface.  There is way more to
this, so there is a talk
tomorrow going into detail on
stage 6 at 9:30 that talks about
how PWA and AMP work together.
Next up is Elena talking about
the challenges of AMP.
>> ELENA LEGEROS: Thanks.
So as an open source initiative,
we feel like it's really
important to be transparent in
acknowledging that not
everything about AMP is perfect.
And when the community shares
feedback, AMP gets better.  And
the community has shared a lot
of feedback.  We really
appreciate it.  And so we
thought we would take some time
to share some of the feedback
that we have heard and how we
are working to address some of
those challenges.
have heard is that all AMP pages
look the same.  This can be
true to an extent.  We admit
that we need to make it easier
for publishers to build unique
AMP pages that represent their
own brand identities.  We have
also heard feedback from
publishers having a hard time
accurately measuring the success
of their AMP pages.  And to be
honest, we  messed up a little
bit here.  It's currently
challenging to get metrics
right.  Another category of
feedback we have heard is around
AMP URLs displayed in Google
Search and I will talk a little
bit more about this.  And
another thing that we have heard
is that AMP pages do not
monetize well through ads.  It's
true that there are a number of
restrictions on bad ad
behavior.  However, even with
these limitations we are
surprised to get this
montization feedback.
So I will go through each of
the points of feedback and talk
about how we are addressing
them.  So starting with the
first one that all AMP pages
look the same.  First of all,
like all Web pages, AMP pages
are styled in CSS and are fully
customizable.  Anyone can build
and contribute to the library of
custom AMP components that
allow for creative faith design
and  flexibility.  And that
library of components is
constantly growing with feedback
from the community.
And one new component that
gives designers more
flexibility is paralax.  The
paralom extension allows for an
element on a page to move as if
it is nearer or farther relative
to the foreground on a page
when the user scrolls producing
a 3D-like effect.  But we
realize that not everyone is a
designer or has designer
resources, and we really needed
to take that into consideration.
And so this past spring we
announced AMP start.  And AMP
start is a set of templates that
can get anyone started quickly
with AMP documents.  And it
eliminates a lot of the heavy
lifting in terms of the design
work.  And we are working on
building out this set of
templates that people
can choose from and modify to
build their own unique AMP
pages.  And if you want to learn
more about building beautiful
interchactive AMP pages, be
sure to check out the talk
that's entirely devoted to this
topic on Friday afternoon the
3:30.
So another point of feedback
is that it's currently
challenging to get AMP metrics
right.  And the first thing I
want to say is that AMP is still
relatively new.  And it really
pushes the boundaries in terms
of the kinds of user experiences
that you can create.  And in
insuring that content is as fast
as it possibly can be, it takes
advantage of things like
platform caching and pre
pre-rendering.  And some of
these things make it a little
bit challenging to measure AMP.
And in the last few months we
have launched a few features
like link and form
substitutions to better sa sift
publishers in attributing page
visits back to AMP.
And we have also published
documentation to illustrate
techniques that people can use
when collecting their own
Analytics directly.  And we are
also really committed to working
with vendor partners to insure
that they are incorporating
updates and building features to
support more reliable and
accurate AMP metrics.
Yesterday actually Google
Analytics announced the rollout
of an enhancement that unifies
users across AMP and non-AMP
pages served from a website's
domain.  This is really going to
improve user analysis across
the two formats.  This change is
going to take effect over the
yap coming weeks -- upcoming
weeks and is the first in a few
plan changes that will enhance
AMP traffic understanding for
Google Analytics clients.
that not everyone likes AMP
URLs d isplayed in Google
Search.  More specifically we
have heard user and publisher
feedback that it isn't easy to
copy and paste links to articles
on AMP.  And it's frustrating
to not be able to access the
original article  URL and to
that we would say that we agree
and actually the AMP project
adopted the guidance that
platforms that  are linking to
AMP content should share
original article ucials when
this is technically possible.
Google Search has just rolled
out a button across mobile Web
in the AMP viewer header where
users can tap to display the
puck lisher link and tap on the
link itself to navigate to the
conical, and long press to copy
paste.  And on native apps where
we have more control over
sharing functionality, we always
chair the publisher URL.
And the last thing I want to
address is the feedback that AMP
pages do not monetize well with
apps.  The Google ad exchange
actually ran tests comparing
monetization for the same
publisher across their AMP and n
on-AMP pages.  And what they
found was that over 90% of
publishers experienced higher
click through rates and over 70%
of publishers experienced
higher viewability on their AMP
pages.
And what we realized was that
the publishers who had been
under p erforming on their AMP
pages were actually just putting
fewer ads on their AMP pages.
But when comparing apples to
apples in terms of ad placement,
monetization results on AMP
pages exceed non-AMP pages.
They do b etter.  So that's a
great segue to Chen Shay who is
going to talk about AMP ads.
(Applause).
Elana.  So if you remember I was
just talking about being a new
mom and what I wanted to tell
you is that I am the perfect
demographic for advertisers.
Advertisers love people like me
because I'm about to buy a bunch
of baby things.  I have no
previous knowledge about the
things I'm about to buy, and I
have zero brand loyalty.  I
don't know who makes what.  I'm
going to learn all of that soon.
Advertisers love my
demographic.  But remember, I'm
also sleep deprived so I'm tired
because I didn't get to sleep
at night and I'm hungry because
I didn't have time to eat and I
have a crying baby.
So do you think that when I
open a page I'm going to sit
there and wait for a slow ad to
load?  No way.  Nobody waits for
slow ads to load.  Least of all
me, and I'm the perfect
demographic that they want to
advertise to.
If an ad wants to be seen, it
better load quickly.  So AMP
made pages lightning fast, but
ads are slow and we wanted to
fix this.  We wanted to make
sure that ads can load at the
same speed as our AMP pages as
the content on the AMP pages.
And when we looked at ads we
realized that ads have the same
problem as regular Web pages.
They are slow.  They are
disruptive.  They have unwanted
JavaScript with no perm
performance guarantees and they
are potentially unsafe.  This is
something we really care about.
We want to make sure our users
have a safe online experience.
So what we did was we applied
the same performance principles
of AMP to   ads and we called
it AMP ads.  AMP ads are ads
that are created in AMP format.
And they are fast because they
have no third party JavaScript,
and all of the code is
guaranteed to be performance
optimized.  And they are light
because they have reasonable
components like AMP Analytics
and AMP Pixel which collect all
of the information one time and
then they give it to authorized
vendors, and what this does by
collecting information only one
time, it relieves the burden on
the browser.  And they are safe
because we sign all of our AMP
ads to insure that they are
valid so they shouldn't contain
any m aladvertising.
So I will show you a
difference between an AMP ad and
a regular ad, and what happens
was triple lift they ran a bunch
of AMP ads and regular a ds
side by side and they ran them
on AMP pages and let's see what
the difference looks like.  So
on the right we have a regular
ad.  It's taking forever to
load.  There is no way I'm going
to wait for that ad to load,
not in a million years but on
the left side we is an AMP ad
and it loads instantaneously.
I'm definitely going to have a
chance to see that one.  And on
top of that, triplelift reported
that AMP ads when compared to
regular ads are three times
lighter, six times faster and
they generate more revenue for
publishers.
So AMP ads are wonderful, but
how do you build them?  Well,
you can build them yourself just
like an AMP page.  Or you can
use various t ools that are
available to you such as
Celtra's ad creator tool.  Let's
take a look.  This is an editor
and the cool thing about this
is that you can create AMP ads
using this editor without having
any technical knowledge.  I
highly recommend you try it out.
pioneers that implement support
for AMP ads and there are a lot
more in the process.  We have
publishers delivering AMP ads to
their Web pains.  We have --
pages, you can sign your AMP a
ds with Google or CloudFlare.
There are various creative tools
you are welcome to use to
create AMP ads and there are
more and more ad servers
beginning to support AMP.  So we
have the entire ecosystem.  And
overall, our vision is to make
AMP  *78 AMP ads the defact to
standard for ads on the Web.  If
you want to learn more about
AMP ads we have an entire
session dedicated to talking
just about that tomorrow morning
at 8:30 on stage 5.  And I know
it's really early, but what's
more important than talking
about ads at 8:30 in the
morning?  So h opefully we will
see you all there.  To wrap
things up I would like to
welcome back Malte Ubl.
(
Applause).
>> MALTE UBL: I want to talk
about contributing to AMP, to
AMP is an open source project.
I manage the team at Google that
works full time on this
project, but we, you know, we
really want to, want this to be
an open project and we want to
have your, we would like to have
your contribution to it.  We as
a project we live on GitHub and
it has been a bit top lar.  We
crossed through 10,000 stars
which I don't really know what
that means but I'm excited about
T. but way more important over
400 of you have been
contributing with actual pull
requests with our own code for
the AMP project, and I think
this kind of proves it's truly
distributed, meaningful open
source project.  We don't want
to stand still at this stage so
we did a few things over the
last months to make the project
more transferrant and increase
the level of engagement for the
community to be a part of AMP.
One thing we have done is we
have launched this weekly design
reviews on hangouts.  So here
is a picture of my team but
there are people on the hangout
that allows everyone to go to
our GitHub issue we create every
week and say we would like to
discuss this topic.  You are on
the agenda and you can discuss
whatever you want to change
about AMP with the AMP Core team
and can become a member of the
AMP Core team and when I saw,
that includes us.  Every single
change we make, we create a
design Doc and we put it on the
agenda of this meeting and
discuss it with the community
and you get to be a part of
that.
I'm most excited to announce
that later this year we will
have the first ever AMP
contributor seminar.  We will
invice  contributors to
mountainview to discuss things
in person.  How do you
contribute to A MP?  Not
everyone is a seasoned open
source developer and knows all
of these things.  So what we
created was a set of great first
issues.  These are essentially
tutorials that teach you step by
step what you need to do to
create your first AMP commit.
Go to bit.LY/AMP for details on
this.  We would like you to get.
You don't have to know what
GitHub is.  It should be really
good.  Now, as I said, we are
living on GitHub.  So that's the
main URL.  You will find all of
the detail there's but you can
create issue there's so you
don't have to write code.  You
will find the URL for the Slack
on GitHub and you can contribute
and talk to us in person.  You
can join the weekly hangout.
You can ping us on Twitter.  We
are really active.  You can come
to stack overflow or write our
mailing list if that's your
thing.  The mailing list address
is on the GitHub URL.
Final thing is just to point
you to all of the other AMP
talks we have, tomorrow morning
if you are really early you can
catch the AMP ads t alk.  Eight
roof that really exciting talk
about AMP and PWAs and then
finally Friday stage 6, 3:30
talk of building beautiful AMP
pages for eCommerce and beyond.
Just recapping things we have
talked about AMP having really
great momentum in both
publishing and platforms.  We
call it open for business so if
you are in eCommerce, please
start building AMP pages.  If
you are looking at building a
PWA, AMP might be a first great
step towards PWA and we are
hoping for AMP ads to fix
advertising on the W eb.  Thank
you very much.  We are going to
hang out in the app  AMP S
andbox.  Hope to see you there.
Thank you very much.
(Applause).
(Concluded at 8:39CT).